🎵
Yippee!
🎵 🎵 🎵 Condense!
Condense!
Condense milk!
That's our ingredients!
Condense milk.
Your toes.
Konichiwagwan.
Yeah, where did you guys find shoes?
Wait, I just realized I'm the only one without shoes.
So, it's Vicky and I's first time playing, and both of us
have something wrong with this.
Vicky's got toes out.
They are, like, really out.
There's the, like, hobbit feet.
Those are...
Toes out for the lads.
Woo!
And then...
And I...
I didn't have the option to select a username.
So what am I...
I can't be my own titan six six five.
That's me quartz titan six six five.
Ready to play high tail.
Just so you guys know there is some deep lore behind this,
but we'll have to, we'll have to, uh, we'll have to wait and
find out.
Yeah.
Through the course of the game.
Ooh, the quartz titan.
Don't give her quartz.
She goes crazy.
Can you mine quartz in this, in this game, I wonder?
Yeah.
I don't know, actually.
Are you guys ready to explore the world of Hytale?
Yay!
Oh my gosh, I just noticed it's raining.
I guess this is Hytale the UK then.
Hytale the UK is crazy.
Welcome to...
Is it true?
It's always raining.
Oh.
Yes.
Oh, yes, Minto.
Show us the way.
No, no.
Yes, show us the way.
I will...
You guys explore and do...
Whatever you want.
The world is your oyster.
Oh.
I mean, the last time I did whatever I want, I already lost
health getting burnt in the fire.
Yeah, you did.
In the starting area?
Yeah, this is the starting area.
Ooh.
We got around here.
I have played Hytale a couple times.
Yeah, grab some berries.
And I heard you liked it a lot, right?
I do.
I hope that it doesn't die.
It might.
That's fine, too.
How do I...
Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry, babe.
No, it's okay.
You didn't do any physical damage.
Just emotional damage.
Oh, no, I think I forgot to turn on player PvP.
Oh, man.
Oh, is that an important part of the experience?
Oh.
It could be.
But I think we're okay.
how how do we eat stuff grab it and then shove it in your
mouth oh sorry sorry sorry sorry okay shove it in my mouth
yeah with the right click down right click yeah you have to
hold it down yeah there's like a little bar that shows up oh
nice oh thank you so much thank you i thought it was very
stylish yes oh look someone over there look yeah Let's go
have a look.
Oh wait, they have an axe.
Okay, never mind.
You look kind of angry.
Never mind.
Can we attack with a bury?
Can you punch him with your bear space?
Kill him!
I don't know if this is...
Oh, yeah.
Oh, guys.
Yeah...
Yes, with all best.
Sorry, I got distracted with flower picking.
I want to give it to you, but I don't know how.
That's so Phoebe-coded.
Oh, my God.
I think it's tea.
You can get that.
My lady.
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
Because you guys are the sunshine of my life.
Sunflowers for my sunshines.
Aw.
That's so sweet.
I will keep it close to my heart.
What else have I got?
Linen scraps.
Where are these from?
Did I, like, rip off your guys' clothes by accident?
Sorry if I did.
No, you stole the clothes off that guy.
Oh, is that what happened?
Oh.
What is the skeleton he hopes for?
I guess he died in them.
Probably.
Because fashion.
You're right.
Who wants to deny someone fashion beyond the grave?
Look at that.
Look at Mint.
She's fashionable beyond the grave.
Yeah, exactly.
I'll close.
Oh, it'd be pretty bad if I didn't.
Oh, wait.
You like blue.
This is for you, Victor.
I do.
They look like forget-me-notes.
My favorite flower.
Oh, yeah, they're cute.
That is your favorite flower.
Wait, Minto, what's your favorite flower?
Hydrangea.
Oh, that's a good one, too.
You guys have very based flower taste.
Is there such a thing as based flower taste?
There's a based anything.
Yeah.
I misheard you at first and thought you said basic flower
takes and I was about to be like oh my gosh Phoebe okay I
feel like mine's kind of basic oh really you think so there
are some people that don't even know how to pronounce
hydrangea wow you were purporting yeah I got attacked by a
guy I didn't know this was their home yeah there's some guys
oh mature wheat you guys live like this yeah you should take
it can we get some bread make some bread we could make bread
we could yeah let's do it oh hello baby oh i'm beating up
the guys that whose house you uh oh i'll kid this guy from
behind they only aggro on one person because they're stupid
i'm making a tactical retreat are you dying eat berries oh i
am i'm dying oh hold on hold on the berry the berries just
keep that oh no i made the baby where are you oh and let me
keep my flowers though that's good i'll just stop it i die
stop it stop stop okay i know i i attacked yeah just just
beat him up while i run away um if i can catch up with you
guys going fast like sonic okay gotta go fast can i just say
you're too slow funny seeing chat speak with random this at
the end of everything yeah what is going on with that yeah
youtube's being real He's broken.
You got him?
Yeah, you got him.
You got him.
Keep beating him up.
I got him trapped.
Yeah, yeah.
He's slow.
Come here.
Come here, you.
You're too slow.
Oh, that was so cool, Vicky.
They killed him.
You're too slow.
Yeah.
There's something in here.
This is our house now.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
There's something down here, guys.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Green flat cat mushroom.
Um.
Oh!
Ouch!
Don't come down here.
Oh.
Come down here carefully.
Come down here.
Oh, I see.
Me and Phoebe are, you know, taking the stairs.
Oh, oops.
Yeah, that's how happened to me too.
Oh, we were taking the stairs.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, there you are.
Oh, wait, is there another guy?
Take this berry.
Shoot.
Hey!
I'm about to die.
I'm back.
Shit.
Oh, shoot.
Don't worry.
I'll come back.
Find you guys.
Oh, I got him.
Don't worry.
I'm taking him down.
I got one.
We got one.
Cool.
There's two.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, move.
It's okay.
We're close to home.
Oh, let me keep my flowers again.
Good.
I think I remember what you guys are.
Oh, my gosh, cows.
We're right behind you, Vicky.
Oh, my gosh.
They're Highland cows.
They're my favorite type of cows.
No way.
Oh, my gosh.
Why do you like?
Highland cows the best because because they the the the the
hair covers their eyes.
They look they look all emo, you know It's very sweet.
I'm gonna punch a tree I'm gonna punch a cow I'm gonna punch
a tree too.
Yeah, if you with another wood.
It's better than Minecraft because look at watch what
happens Whoa, yeah Very satisfying.
Isn't it?
Okay, I'm going to make us weapons.
Give me one second.
Oh, bless.
Let me remember how to do this.
It's just like Minecraft.
You have to make like a crafting table and stuff.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, I need stone.
Oh,
no.
I don't think we're winning this Deschat.
Please.
What do you mean?
What do they think?
What do they know?
We're winning.
We found Highland Cows.
We literally have taken three places.
from skeletons from their home yeah taking three steps from
the spawn point it's better than any player you know how
there's like steam achievements that like is an achievement
from the very beginning of the game but it says like only 30
percent of players have this yeah that's that's us right now
can i bring any crafting materials hold on i'll get i'll
make you a weapon
that fiber oh i'm gonna make this campfire yeah and then
maybe we can cook with said campfire yeah yeah open campfire
all right there's a weapon for somebody and there's another
weapon for somebody oh what we got oh what's this oh did i
take it you got a crude sword yeah you took it How do I how
do I find it?
Uh, tap?
Tab.
Ooh!
Crude soul.
I have two.
Wait, I think I took two by accident.
That's okay.
Just give the throw the other one to Freibs.
I think I, I think I did it.
Yippee!
Yay!
Did you get it?
All right, nice.
Yeah.
Now we can go kill those guys.
Yeah, we can kill them.
Yes, yes.
Revenge, revenge!
I'm ready.
Where'd you guys go?
Down the hole.
I'm in the hole.
Oh, be careful about falling.
Oh yeah, I see the hole.
Um, hold on.
I'm gonna, I'm, oh, that's not what I meant to do.
This.
Come here, baby, I'll catch you.
Really?
I'm gonna make a stairs.
Oh, so sweet.
I'm a, I'm an engineer.
This is women in STEM.
Yes!
This is women in STEM!
Okay.
Arm.
One moment, please.
What's stem against science, tech, engineering, and...
And crafting.
Clearly.
Yeah, the M is silent and crafting.
Oh.
Oh, the...
Oh, you were spelling STEM!
Wait, STEM stands for something?
Wait!
Don't it!
It does!
That's why swimming in STEM is!
Wait, so what is it again?
Science or murder?
Science!
Murder?
Science, math?
Oh, math!
Tech?
Wait, what's the rest of it?
In engineering, I think.
Eggman.
Ouch.
STEM really counts for Sonic Tails.
Eggman.
And math.
Math.
Maths.
I love the way you guys say math.
How do you say it?
Maths.
Oh maths.
Like multiples.
Maths.
Oh I found a special room.
What's in the special room?
In the special box.
I got some special things.
Hello?
Oh, who is attacking me now?
Someone else?
Oh, yeah, they come out.
Be gone.
Oh, no!
Who was attacking you?
Wait, where did that come from?
This guy.
Oh, it's too dark.
I can't see what's going on.
I think you got him.
Is he dead?
Oh, yeah, you get him.
Yeah, noisoo.
Okay, I should probably eat some...
Nice.
Yeah, eat some berries.
Eat some wheat.
I don't think you can eat wheat.
Raw wheat.
You can.
You can eat raw wheat.
You can?
Yeah.
what oh dang there's a lot of treasure in here all right can
i eat sunflowers the flowers that phoebe lovingly picked for
me oh it's edible that's wonderful wait do you guys want um
uh a torch oh i'm going mushroom yes guys a bookcase
education education women in stem math wait how do i throw
just one i don't remember uh oh yeah There you go.
Oh, hello.
There's a dude.
Oh, he's trapped, though.
Lamau, come and look at this.
He's trapped, so he can't attack us.
Ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha.
Wait, how do I get down there?
Where is he?
Oh, in the...
You can't get us.
On the other hand, can we poke him through the window?
Yeah, probably.
Oh.
Come here.
Can anyone see anything?
thing um it's hard however i killed him you can maybe
there's a guy right next to you like in the corner this guy
is blare witching right now oh he is oh wow here we go he's
just kind of having a moment yeah maybe maybe hello leaving
oh no one left behind no one left behind oh this guy yeah
this
him through the by the way the rats are not friends oh oh
they're very sweet though no they see they're deceiving well
i got some nice raw wild meat for the rat i need to look at
that again i need to look at what the dead rat looks like
the dead rat they look at him look at him goodbye remy
Open it, open it, open it.
Oh my gosh.
Copper ore.
Lesser health potion.
Wilson here.
Iron ore.
Any quartz?
No, no quartz for quartz king or whatever.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Quartz Titan 665.
Look right here at this pile at the right standing on top of
it.
Quartz Titan 665 sees it.
It is quartz.
Can I just grab it?
Oh, I'm going to catch on fire.
Oh, it's me!
Oh my gosh, sorry, I'm on fire.
Oh, we're all on fire.
We're all on fire.
This girl is on fire.
Ouch.
There was somebody at the door.
Oh, God, they're coming.
Mental, I think you were the most formidable foe.
Like, no one, no, you have not died yet.
Wait, yes, I have.
Oh.
Yeah, I did.
That's okay, though.
I'll take that.
Yeah, I didn't, I didn't die.
Oh, wait, this is my new favorite snack.
Hey, there's quite a lot of people down here.
Yeah.
Scary.
Ow.
But also some fun blue stuff.
Oh, owey, owey.
Are you okay?
Ow, okay, I'm going back.
Yeah.
Yowey's an owey.
Hold on.
Yowey's an owl.
Oh, he's coming after you.
He's coming.
Ouch.
Oh.
Wait.
Are you okay?
I hate that they know how to block.
The berries do like no healing.
No, they don't.
You got it.
Here, do you need a health potion?
What?
behind you there's a little scrum oh oh my gosh i'm saying
fire again oh oh wow what's that what'd you grab oh damn oh
did i pick something up yeah you picked up his weapon he was
like an axe or something scrap mace nice oh
hey oh i'm eating what was that food you were eating i look
good some fish here i my raw wheat oh thank you oh heck yeah
anybody want a veggie skewer cooked wild meat oh i'll take
it i'll take it yeah oh lovely lovely there you go veggie
skewer veggie skewer thank you this will save my life oh oh
oh i picked up by accident how do i put it back no no i gave
you one i gave you one I had a couple, yeah.
Woo-hoo!
We're eating good today, barbecue.
Whoa!
Barbecue.
And we're in a good old barbecue.
Alright.
Ooh, there's a ladder here.
Oh, there's also an enemy.
No, this guy is fine.
He's just a bet.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I'm glad they're friendly.
Oh, there is actually...
What's going on in here?
There is a chest.
I hear some banging.
Yeah, me too.
Oh, there's nothing else in here.
Was there anything fun inside?
Just some some some supplies.
I got some I got some seeds.
We're gonna make a farm Yay, oh hello.
Oh,
what's going on?
Oh, there's a lot going on.
Oh, there's a lot of guys.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't have my sword out That's why.
Okay, that's probably useful.
Okay, got him.
Nice.
Boy, yeah, we're getting all the supplies.
This is nice.
Woohoo!
This is great.
This place is awesome.
Oh, there's a guy on fire.
Oh, and he died because of the fire.
Stupid head, stupid head.
Seeds!
We can farm.
Farm, no, no.
Become a...
Agricultural society.
No, no.
Oh, me, me, no.
I just watched him die.
In the lava?
Yeah.
I have to pick up quartzite rubble.
Yeah, we gotta get all the quartz.
Everything.
And then finally, I'll be able to live out my destiny.
As your course tied in 665.
Yeah.
I wonder if at this point I should even bother changing my
username.
It's kind of iconic.
Yeah, you shouldn't.
It's too iconic.
It's too good.
Quartz Titan 665.
I don't even know if you can change it.
Oh no!
I was joking.
Who else will be our Quartz Warrior if we do not have Quartz
Titan?
You're right.
There can only be one Quartz Titan 665.
Yeah!
Oh, there's a ladder, but you have to jump the lava.
Oh, is there?
We can make it.
We make it.
I want to see at least one person make it.
Oh, you did it!
Oh, that was the same.
Yay, yay, yay, yay.
Yippee!
You can do it, Vento!
I feel like I almost didn't.
I was scared for a second.
anything over here power oh there's a there's another chest
why was this suddenly weird music what's up the ladder febes
this place is uh there was a mushroom skewer and a few other
things inside of a chest wow nice if anyone needs stamina
potions oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no okay it's fine it's
fine i'm good i went you look like you're dancing a little
bit i need food can i eat Here's some fruit skewers.
Oh, thank you.
Fruit skewer.
Okay.
Fruit a skewer.
Actually, you know what I hear?
I'm going to give you this potion of health, too.
Oh, thanks.
Much appreciated.
We're, like, totally exploring.
This is crazy.
Well, there's so many chests in here.
Whoa, this is, like, some legit place.
What the heck?
Yeah.
Oh, this is where we were just fighting earlier.
No, I think this is new.
Oh!
So many vegetable skewers, you guys!
There's so much stuff in here!
Holy moly.
Whoa.
These guys were living in luxury.
I just wish my inventory would automatically consolidate
things into stacks.
Uh, if you press...
So when you open up a chest, there's a little...
down arrow called take it says it's take all you can do it
like that oh there's a take all button oh yeah thank you
that's the third chest i've opened there's nothing in it oh
sorry i think i it's okay no no that's good i trust you guys
with the with the loot more than i trust me all right here
we go copper down here nikki do you need any food no i think
i'm good i'm i'm full health thanks guys we're exploring
we're mining and crafting Well, we're kind of just mining.
Oh, chat, thank you.
They told me that food is here over time.
I did not realize.
Yeah, just a little bit.
Oh, I'm back.
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm back.
Thanks, guys.
Yeah, thanks, guys.
I'm back.
Oh, wait, Mito, how'd you get up there?
You're so bad.
Look at this.
Look at this over here.
Come over here.
You get up here.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Look at, look at over here.
Oh, I see.
You see?
Oh, hello.
Oh, I love you.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, oh, that's a bad guy.
No, look at these guys.
Oh, it's a bad.
Look at these.
Oh, wow.
Are they friends?
Oh, hello.
Oh, hi.
We're in a spider's nest.
Oh.
Oh, you.
Is that, are these spiders or are these victims?
These are the victims.
Oh, that is a, that's a bad guy.
Oh, that's a friend.
Oh, no, no, no, no, none of them are friends.
You know, yeah, Phoebe, there's very few friends in this
game, actually.
Think about it.
The guy that Phoebe would love, though.
Little guy.
Yeah, I know.
He's so cute.
I really liked him.
Yeah, he's cute.
Yeah, I'm gonna give you guys some torches.
Oh, I think I grabbed some.
Yeah, here you go.
Oh, thanks.
Yeah.
You can equip them in the menu.
There's like, you can put them in your other hand.
Did someone take two?
Also, there is offhand.
I see.
I don't think I took one.
Oh, you did it?
Oh, wait, what is...
May I have a torch?
Yes.
Here.
Thank you.
Oh, you got it?
Wait.
Oh, where did I put mine?
Oh, wait.
Uh, did someone grab my torches?
Wait.
Wait, what are my torches?
Oh, wait.
Now I have three.
Wait.
Hang on.
Where'd my go?
How do I give you guys a torch?
G.
Yeah.
G?
Yes.
Baby, baby, baby.
Wait, I think I got it.
G, G, G, G.
Oh, hello, spider.
Oh, they're cute.
Oh, they're poisonous, too.
Look at this little guy.
Oh, dear.
Okay, so we don't want to anger it.
So you can right-click and it will block.
Oh, now you're poisoned.
Oh.
Oh, hello, little one.
Hello.
I'm sorry.
You must kill the little guy.
You must kill.
Oh, he's so cute.
That's a crime.
They should not have designed it so cute.
I know.
He's like just a little baby.
Oh, I think you got poison.
Yeah, I think you were poison.
Oh.
Wait, so can I just open these?
Oh, yeah, you'll get there.
Oh, my gosh, I'm nearly dead.
What?
Oh, ow.
I'm nearly dead.
Oh, my gosh.
What am I going to do?
Um, quickly get that health potion.
Use it.
The health potion.
We're guarding you.
Yeah, we're guarding you.
Also, uh...
Okay.
I already got you.
Take that.
Oh, thanks.
And this.
Thanks, guys.
Okay.
Oh, how is that happening?
I feel refreshed.
What was that?
What is happening?
You currently look like a mommy from Madoka to me.
Huh?
Oh, you're fine now.
Oh, oh, oh, I saw...
Yeah.
You were...
Yeah, you're fine now.
You're fine.
Oh, awesome.
But it's not unusual to see a headless Vicky.
That's so true.
Oh, I want a mine.
a cute group uh like we could get fan art of us in in like
maruka outfits that'd be so cute vicky has like a really
cute mommy yeah do we just punch it um oh there's some oh
yeah i don't have a oh hold on i'll give you guys one after
i kill this guy hold on let me pick up uh they're bad guys
Oh, ow, ow, ow, ow, hold on, just a...
They're just annoying little...
Yeah.
Uh, here, uh, here's a pickaxe for somebody.
Pickaxe?
Oh, thank you.
And I can make another one.
Here's another pickaxe for somebody.
I have a hatchet.
Thank you.
Yeah, did you grab it?
Yeah!
I don't think I grabbed it.
Oh, did someone else grab it?
What did I have in your pocket?
What did I grab?
Do you have the...
Do you have another pickaxe in your pocket?
Oh.
Um, yes I do.
I'm so sorry.
No, it's okay.
Uh, okay.
Let me give you this one?
Dozo?
Thank you.
People just throwing things on the ground in these games.
They can't just hand you something like a civilized...
Nah.
There's...
It's just...
We're in life or death situations.
There's no time for friendly, you know.
handing over.
You must toss it on the ground.
You must toss it.
With conviction.
Like, huh.
Yeah.
What's for you?
Next time I see you guys in person, I'm gonna bring your
gifts and you're like, here, just throw them on the floor.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna be able to make so much stuff.
Wait, this is the...
This is crazy.
Woo!
You!
Get away!
Wait!
Are you okay?
It was real dark.
I thought I had my torch in my off hand.
Oh, I can't if it's a two-handed weapon.
Okay, let me see.
Yeah, yeah, if you're using your thing specifically.
Oh, yeah, I'm mining right now, guys.
This is a crazy copper fan.
I'm, like, going deep.
I've gotten 22 so far.
Where are you, Minto?
I'm in deep.
It just don't stop.
Oh, I see.
Deeper in.
Okay.
I'm at 25.
Oh, my God.
It just don't stop.
How are they?
What, like, going further down, yeah?
Yeah, I'm rich.
I'm rich in copper.
I'm going to make so many pennies.
Whoa.
Whoa, Vicky, are you okay?
Yes.
Okay, you fell down, down.
Okay, I'll come with you.
Ooh, there's some, like, pretty...
Hello?
Oh!
There's a rat behind me.
What is that?
It's glowing.
It's so...
glowing oh my god this guy oh he just followed me what the
hell what are you what are you i like you what are you
where'd you guys go where is it down down down down shiny
guy down he's a little shiny guy there's a shiny guy do i
what do i do with him oh my gosh what is that uh i don't
know but i like it oh geez are you guys okay oh my gosh they
are so strong what um i think i'm doing No, no, just leave.
Just leave.
Oh, I got his weapon.
I died.
I will avenge you.
Oh, no.
Wait, you guys went down, down.
Wait, not the magma toad.
Oh, no.
Wait, are you guys okay?
Magma.
The rhino toad.
They're dead now.
They're dead now, but, like...
But, okay, do I just leave Vicky's stuff here?
So, for us, you can just leave it.
Just leave it, guys.
I'll come find you.
Where are you, guys?
Oh, I think I see...
Oh, geez.
Oh, what is this little snail?
Should I...
Oh, you went to hell.
You went to hell.
Yeah, I can't believe you went to hell.
What?
Shoot.
Um, how do I get you out?
Oh, this little shiny, shiny guy.
Oh, I like you.
Sarah.
Oh, you- whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What are you?
No!
Be gone!
Oh, there he is.
I think I hear you, but I don't see you.
I got a bunch of bombs.
Ah!
Oh, wait.
No, wait.
What the hell am I?
Do anything?
Wait.
Oh, I see you!
I see you up there!
I see you!
I saw you!
Oh, I see you!
You're coming to- Okay.
Okay, I'll come down.
I'm coming down.
Ouch.
I'm fine.
Careful.
I'm okay.
There's this shiny guy over here.
And all the Vicky stuff.
And then there's also a snail.
All right, I'll grab what I can.
No, no, it's okay.
I'm putting my...
map reading into use we okay oh the snail is so cute it's
very cute the music is kind of scary this shiny guy oh wait
where do you go oh this this guy this guy um you could kill
him for some magma stuff oh kill you could kill are you
ready to become a murderer oh this guy these guys are so
annoying the scrum goes i hate them oh be careful of toad
now it's going in the direction of We gotta go.
We gotta go.
I'm gonna eat stuff real quick.
Okay, I'm gonna build us a way up.
Wait, let's not do that.
Okay.
I feel like my game is perhaps very...
Very quiet.
Wait, where is that?
How do we get up?
That's a good question.
I think I found you guys.
Oh wait, but if you guys are underground, then does it
matter that I've...
Okay, I'm gonna just have to dig deep.
No, no!
We'll come up to you!
Honestly, we could like...
Oh, wait, where is the entrance?
Uh, I'm lost, actually.
Don't follow me.
Um...
I'ma dig down!
She's digging down!
Uh...
Where did the shiny guy go?
Oh, geez.
Okay, we beat these guys up before.
We can do it again.
He's so evil though.
He's so evil.
Really evil.
Wait, is he dead?
Yeah.
Wait, you keep spawning back in.
Go away.
Yeah, I think they have, like, a house close by.
Oh.
Oh, there's a shiny thing.
I should have just smacked it while I had it.
The guy?
Oh, we can get him.
He's pretty cute, though.
He's really cute.
But we also...
I will find you guys.
Destroyed the cute worms earlier.
Oh, oh!
You want to get that, Mint?
Yeah.
Oh, the sword?
I have one.
Or his mace or whatever.
Yeah, the weapon.
Oh.
You want to go into hell.
Now Vicky can have one as well.
But now Vicky can have one.
I'm committed to this, guys.
I'm just in a one square hole just digging straight down.
Eventually I will find you.
I believe.
You might want to watch out, Phoebe.
Okay.
Did I do it?
Did I get something from that?
Did you?
I'm not certain.
Uh.
This is a wild first place to go.
Yeah, this is crazy.
Whoa, there's like a tree and stuff here.
This is like a little house.
Where?
Where are you?
Let me see the map.
I'm digging directly down.
We're like a little...
Hmm.
Oh, I'm like...
Okay, I'm gonna turn the other way.
Okay.
We could also all just die.
I'm gonna try being this way.
Because you know it's forgiving in the way that you do get
to keep some of your stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can change it too where you get to keep all your stuff.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh?
Oh, I see.
I see something.
You do?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, guys.
I might be there.
No way.
Okay.
Oh, maybe.
Phoebe, do you know how to open the map?
Uh, is it M?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Look where she is.
Oh.
Wait, what?
I mean, you're not super far.
It's just, uh...
You know, you're on your way.
You're on your way.
We're waiting.
I'm finding stuff.
Yeah?
Okay.
That's good.
What kind of stuff we find.
Perhaps you're...
Yeah.
Lots of cobblestone.
I could see something!
Bait it!
Wait, okay.
Really?
Can you see me?
I think I'm in the cave again.
Oh!
Okay, maybe we have wandered a little bit.
Let's try to find our way back.
Yeah, yeah.
Where we came from.
Vicky, if you open map, you'll find us.
Oh, this guy is loose.
No, no, you were...
Okay.
Um...
This way...
He's trying to get to us.
I don't know, actually.
I think he's stupid.
I wonder.
We're down.
Oh!
He throws bombs.
Ouch.
Yeah, I got him.
Maybe?
Yeah.
Okay, I must be close.
Oh!
Oh shoot!
How close are you guys to the giant lava pool?
Um, uh, above it?
Perhaps.
Nice.
I don't think it is.
Snail.
Little snail.
I like the snail.
Hi snail.
Have you guys played snail simulator yet?
No, but I've seen it.
No, I've never even heard of it.
I know, right?
I've seen it around.
I definitely want to try it sometime.
I think sometimes I think it'd be fun to reject humanity and
just be snail.
I agree.
Oh, there's more of these guys.
There's so many of these guys!
Oh my god.
It's almost like they live here and we're invading their
home or something.
Oh, watch out.
One thing about this game is that...
Ouch, ouch.
Oh, that got me good.
are kind of aggressive with their respawns oh yeah yeah
noticing is it is this where we were earlier too it is yeah
i was trying to find a way back up but yeah oh my god
there's oh no oh no two frog two frog two of them two of
them hold on i have bombs you do wait that guy is coming
over to you i i picked him up from the bomb guy him though i
think he likes you hi oh i like you too i like Don't go back
over there, no!
Did I get any bombs?
Oh!
Are you okay?
You guys want to meet at the lava- Quartz!
Titan!
Quartz Titan!
I think I'm dead too.
Should I just die in the lava then?
Maybe.
Chico Cave, come on.
Yeah, it's probably a different maybe you guys are so silly
continuing to talk talk in your broken japanese and chat I
love it I think it's huge I think it's back a fix though I
think people are seeming to type normal again but they want
to type like that maybe I think it's become a cultural thing
now Vicky kill yourself we'll all be together again okay I
will I'm just gonna get some based cobble oh no sorry iron
ore oh nice okay i'm dying in the lava i'm gonna take a few
more bites of my breakfast now your breakfast i didn't have
time to eat anything before my first stream earlier oh no
it's breakfast for me almost 5 p.m no
this is a rich tradition usually will not stop desering.
That's okay.
Yeah, don't stop desering.
I was telling my chat earlier that this glitch has helped us
kill the part of us that cringes.
That's true.
Embrace our I am cringe, but I am free.
Do you guys want to explore not inside the caves and instead
see the lands?
Yeah.
Let's do it.
Okay.
We can go anywhere you please if you will open the map and
look around anything that suits your fancy well there's like
a forest up to the left there's a there's a red forest the
circle thing yeah forest oh yeah i see what's that forgotten
temple gateway yeah the forgotten temple oh where is that oh
we're down there Do you want to go?
Should we go?
Yeah, let's go.
I've forgotten temple.
Let's go.
Forgotten temple.
Phoebe, I think you'll like this part of the game.
Oh?
Yeah.
That could be that.
I'm like...
Now my imagination is going wild because that could mean a
number of things.
It's just like a cute little part.
I'm so excited.
Very exciting.
I mean, not going to lie, my favorite so far is...
those highland cows do you know that you can in scotland you
can do like a highland cow experience you can walk a
highland cow no way so bad yeah like walk walk like walk
them around a field yeah i want to do it oh another stop on
our list of places we want to go yeah yeah scotland we can
go see lock nests yeah i want to see lock nests yeah Yeah,
yeah.
All right.
And any other cryptids you guys have?
Like the Lamb of Tartary.
But what?
I'm going to...
What?
Oh, can I just tell you real quick about the...
Oh, I'm sorry, my neurons are activated.
The Lamb of Tartary.
Yeah.
Yes.
Is a cryptid from the UK.
And it's just basically a baby lamb attached by the
umbilical cord to a plant.
And it eats things around it.
Aww.
Is it...
It's like a baby lamb growing on the ground.
I think all cryptids are cute and I think all cryptids are a
little bit mysterious and therefore creepy at the same time.
So it's probably both.
But I want to meet that as well.
I learned recently of the Fresno Nightwalker.
Oh, that was a good one too!
That was so cute, right?
It's in my top three cryptids.
He's so cute.
He just looks like a pair of pants walking.
Some people say it looks like a mongus.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It looks like a mongus.
Yeah.
It's a pair of pants.
It's in the part of California no one thinks about.
Mid-Cal.
Eh?
Yeah.
Damn, there's some legs.
There's some legs, right?
Oh my god, Phoebe, have you played Creature Kitchen yet?
What is Creature Kitchen?
It's a 100% must for you.
Wait, I'm gonna write this down for myself.
I'm gonna Google it so I don't forget.
You need Creature Kitchen.
Oh, it's like literally Phoebe Core game, 100%.
Oh, I'm wishlisting it right now.
What kind of thing is it?
It's got overwhelming positive reviews.
Yeah, it's a creepy cozy cookie simulator when you first...
friend local wildlife and feed them their favorite snacks i
have to you have to i will yeah i will purchase it after
this yeah yes let's go in can i yeah should we keep this
fire burning you can you can even take it if you like it you
take it hours now oh oh my gosh that's ours our temple our
temple sorry ma'am we're taking this it's our yeah we're
We're gonna take the temple.
Take the temple.
Can we take her?
Anything.
Oh, I took her.
I took the statues.
Oh my gosh.
Yo.
We're gonna take the statues.
It looks like you.
Mint figurine.
No, it looks like you, Vicky.
Oh my gosh, does it?
Oh, it does look.
Yeah, it looks like the...
Vicky statue.
Just look like me.
It does.
Oh my gosh, that's so cute.
I'm gonna slumbering deity.
I'm gonna take her around.
with me oh my gosh cute um six there we go yes there's a
little area down here she cats with the slumber yeah we
could take a picture anywhere oh yeah here we go oh we can
take a picture with our limited edition slumbering deity oh
my gosh oh yeah i got her from the loot box or the you know
yeah super rare she's from a blind box yeah blind box oh
yeah phoebe you can get your own Phoebe, look, look, look.
There's a Titan here.
Yeah, yeah, we gotta kill that guy.
Okay.
We can take him out.
Oh, she's not friends.
Okay.
No, unfortunately.
No.
Oh, we got him.
Easy.
Nice.
Chester.
Woohoo.
A chest.
Is that a pool?
Yes, it is.
We should go in.
Corn seeds.
I lost so many of my seeds.
I'm so sad.
Oh no.
It's okay.
I got five corn.
Oh, here.
I have some corn too.
I'll consolidate.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
There's a corn.
Thank you.
Here we go.
Are you ready?
Oh, no.
I'm going to the pool.
Oh, I got him down.
Ooh.
There
we go.
It is.
Oh.
Not me looking at all the flowers being like, I'm gonna pick
them off.
Oh, Phoebe, look at this little bear!
Oh, you got flowers right here!
Oh, you need a flower!
Can I feed you...
Can I feed you berry?
I can't.
I don't think so.
I wish I could pet them.
I know, they're so cute.
Dabs, let us pet them, please.
Are you a bunny?
It's not even a bunny!
It's a jackalope.
It's a cryptid!
Oh my gosh.
They're so cute.
A little cute jackalope.
So there's a...
Oh, you've got flowers in your horn.
Your anglers.
There's an area over here that like once you activate it,
then every creature you see, like it gets added to your like
little memory of creatures.
Oh, look at you little guys.
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to cry.
This is so cute.
Dude, is this thing right here?
This thing.
Yeah.
I'm a fan of this little guy.
He's got very PN eyes.
PN!
Seek out memories of the different creatures.
Your inventory cannot store a limited number of memories
under a special section.
What's he got?
I can get some spices.
Meat pie!
A pie!
Oh, I'd love a pie.
When you buy some pie?
Oh, yes, please, some pie and mash for me.
I don't, I can't, I can't buy it.
I'm too poor.
Oh.
Where's the shop?
Oh, this guy.
Yeah, there's, yeah, there's two of them.
This guy, too.
Is this this guy?
No?
No.
I don't.
I don't know.
All right.
Ooh, I would like this, this pie.
Do we have to purchase from the shop, or might we possibly,
um, forcefully take from the shop if we so, um, if we're so
pleased to do so.
Normally you can't...
And how would you do that, Vicky?
In this area, you can't take anything.
It's kind of lame.
Oh.
Yeah, sadly.
You take memories.
Is anything not under construction anymore?
They, like, did a patch recently.
Oh, what are you?
You're so cute.
Are you a creature?
Hello?
Yeah, the quibs.
Hi.
The quibs.
That's what they'll really...
Did they call quibs?
Yeah, they're called quibs.
Oh.
A meat pie.
Can I become a cleave one day?
Meat pie.
Wait, where do I get the meat pie from?
This guy has it, but you're too poor.
We're too poor for it.
This is an apple pie.
No, he has a recipe for a meat pie.
Oh, really?
Yeah, let's just scroll down.
Would you guys like me to give you the life essence I have
and we can consolidate and maybe buy something?
I just, oh, wait, an amalgamation equivalent to 100 essences
of life.
Oh, but we would need 300.
I have currently 23.
I have 35.
Ah.
Was this- is this the green stuff, how many we have?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have four.
Cool.
I don't- I'm broke, guys.
I told you.
I told you- It's something.
We can come back.
We can- we can harvest a lot of food and come back and get
our meat pa.
Our mate pa.
The meat pie, pie, pie, pie, pie, pie, pie.
Nice meat pie.
Meat pie.
Meat pie, meat pie.
Press F to pick up wooden mug.
Oh wow, so I cannot collect the flowers in this area.
Yeah, you can't do anything in this area, unfortunately.
I see.
So many birds.
What is this?
We're in progress.
Lots of stuff under construction.
What's... Is this like a magical deer look?
Oh no, no, mine.
What's that music?
I know, it's like epic, right?
Come here, this queen.
This queen was so small.
This one is...
Are you even a queen?
Yeah, you could like eat him.
I can.
Why are you eating weebes?
Yeah, stuff him in your mouth.
Look at his ears.
Oh, I could eat you, but I won't.
Oh, when you jump.
I love you.
Was it called a weeb?
Yeah.
He says, I think that's chat right now.
Oh, good.
Good.
Konnichiwa.
I'm weeb, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not, I'm
not, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not.
he's just staring at us while we're making fun of him we're
calling him so bad i'm sorry baby here sorry for you Smash.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
So sorry.
Smash.
To me, it's dead.
Don't worry.
I want to play golf with him.
I will protect you.
This weeb seems like he liked the slumbering deity statue.
Limited edition.
Yeah, he's like, oh yes.
I can put this in my display case from Ikea this.
I put it right next to my Funko Pop and my Hatsune Miku
Okay, but I heard recently That every cultured person has at
least one Hatsune Miku in their house But I feel like a
fraud Because all the Hatsune Miku's in my house Belong to
my housemates Do you guys own your own Miku's?
I feel like you do I only have one, I've never heard that
before, but I've only, I only have one.
At least you have one.
Yeah.
You have one, Vicky?
I don't remember.
Yeah, I can't recall.
Yeah, I do.
I have the, I have the Miku Xenimeral collab figurine.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
Oh, I need to get at least one Miku.
I am uncultured for now.
I believe.
Wait, does it matter?
Like, what if it's like a, like a, like a gacha pon thing,
you know, like something small is okay too?
I think I don't even have that.
I don't even have like a little like blind box me.
I just know how I have no meeku merch.
No meeku at all.
My meeku figure is the pop-up parade vampire figure.
Oh that's a good one.
Yeah it's really cute.
Attachy vampire.
It's a creep.
Kill him.
because why are their meat pies so expensive ridiculous i
know and it's not even for a meat pie it's a recipe i know
oh work in progress oh you're gonna keep me out oh look
you've got weapons to keep us out of work in progress well
if we try and get in there anyway
kill oh i want to get in there such fish yeah they're so
cute oh there's a frog in there I wonder if I can die in
this area.
I wonder.
We can't do anything in it.
I'm going to try.
I'm going to die.
I'm going to kill myself.
Never kill yourself.
I ran out of oxygen, but I'm alive!
Whoa.
This land really is magical.
It is straight up cannot die.
Yeah.
What is this?
Dungeon meshy?
I mean, we did.
did end it through some portal or something yeah I guess I'm
gonna imagine you riding one of these guys you know one of
these little deer with the flower horns I know right into
battle yeah on my flower deer on your flower stag so cute my
flower stag we can go anywhere you guys want to go Yay!
Yay!
As long as we're together.
If you go back to hell, there are dinosaurs apparently.
Oh yeah.
Apparently, so you haven't seen them yet.
I haven't.
It's only a legend.
You need to see the dinosaurs.
I don't know if we'll live.
How do we get to hell?
Um...
We can find a place.
I'll take you there.
Where are we anyway?
Oh, there's like a castle-y looking area over here.
This looks cool.
Let's do it.
I don't like this flock.
Can I get rid of...
Can I take this home?
Yeah, take it.
I am such a kleptomaniac in these games.
Me too.
No, it's fine.
It's there for you to use and take.
And yeah, don't worry about it.
Oh, there's a tower.
That tower thing.
Yeah, that's where I'm headed to.
I wish to see.
Oh, look at this little guy!
Oh, hello!
Yeah, no gonna lie.
It looked cute.
I'm gonna be honest.
It looked cute from farther away.
Did you see its face?
Wait, no, I didn't.
I have not seen it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You've seen something.
Oh, they've seen some stuff, yeah?
Oh, my God.
Oh, but the little baby!
The baby!
We're cute no matter what your face looks like.
Oh, my goodness.
I want to see him for the bird.
He looks so like...
I think the case works better on the baby.
He looks like one of those curly dogs.
Like a small little girl.
He's running around.
I want that.
He wants lettuce!
You want lettuce?
Do I have those?
No.
Wait, no.
I don't even have like the seeds to grow it.
No, just corn.
How about you?
What do you want?
You also want lettuce.
Okay, they both want lettuce.
Wait, I didn't know you could do that.
Oh my god.
There's some healthy sheep.
I don't want chocolate.
I want lettuce.
Hello.
What is this thing above their head?
Is that a status effect?
Oh, no.
It's when you discover them and your memories or whatever.
Oh my god, there's a lot of guys in here.
Be careful.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, okay.
There are a lot.
maybe we should just keep running no we could take um we got
this oh we can take them we can take
them yeah we could take you oh hey oh nice whoa it's coming
down this bone fragments can i eat that purple petals
essence are you hungry are you hungry i've got raw wild meat
but can't eat that can i oh you can't But it just doesn't
give you as much as like a...
Oh, don't worry.
I've got wild berries.
Oh, yeah.
Eat that.
Oh, there are beds here.
Oh, we could steal this as our home.
So we can set respawn points.
Yes, let's steal it.
Wait, where are you guys?
My respawn point.
We're upstairs.
Oh.
Upstairs.
Yeah, come up here.
Hey, you can't block.
I'm blocking.
Beds, but maybe we can share respawn points.
Oh.
Did I get him?
Whoa.
That was sick.
Oh, you saw that?
You saw it.
Yeah.
Wow!
I'm about to die.
Uh-oh.
You want some berries?
I'm gonna eat an apple.
Oh, sorry.
I've got some moss.
Can we eat that?
Moss?
No.
See if I can make a chest.
Too much stuff.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Too many flowers are picked.
This bed!
Aww, cute!
That's a little makeshift.
This is my Ikea bed, Rome.
Because it wasn't built in a day.
This place is huge.
Oh, we got a sunroof.
I'll make a chest.
If you press tab.
Lovely.
If you press tab in the, like, where it's like in the
middle, there's a bunch of stuff.
There should be a wooden chest that you can make i need to
smack some trees i hope you're back yeah it's a lovely view
what a what a nice what a nice little place in the
countryside yeah lovely view beautiful mvp cottage how do i
get back down oh there we go we can refurbish it make it
nice and cute
Hello?
Yeah!
Can you befriend it?
Oh, it's so cute.
Hello?
Oh, it's so sweet.
Is he in our home?
Where is it taking me?
Where'd you find him?
It's near you, baby.
Oh, I see him.
Near me?
So much wood.
Oh, no, why did you attack me?
Why are you attacking me, bro?
Oh, oh.
Why are you attacking me?
Stop!
Come on, man!
I killed you!
No way!
He killed you!
Oh my god!
How did you die?
I will avenge you!
Bro.
What?
Oh, he's so sad there though.
No, he looks so sad.
I feel bad.
Can handle like five skeletons get killed by a fox.
Becky's hair was glitching out.
Oh.
Her hair was glitching out, but then now she has
disappeared.
I didn't even see her.
Did you set your respawn point at the cottage?
How to do that?
Oh.
It's a...
You'll just tap on the bed.
You'll sleep in the bed.
Oh, okay.
I think there's still more skellies in here.
Are you back at spawn?
I think I'm going the right way.
I can see you guys.
Yeah.
slightly more to the the left i believe you i believe in you
thank you this is a crazy place so much stuff oh i think you
guys are free from nihongo jail congrats everybody oh here's
blare but look if you want to keep typing like that we won't
judge you no yeah you're just being safe
Just in case it breaks again.
Yeah, exactly.
It might.
Yes.
Oh.
Oh, how did that?
Hmm.
This game is so relaxing.
Where am I?
Let's see.
I'm going to look where you are.
I think I nearly where you guys are.
You just go past the temple a little bit and you'll see
the...
tower probably.
Gotta display our figures somewhere.
Oh, I have my deity.
My lady.
Oh, I gave it to that weeb in the temple.
Oh, well.
Oh, tough.
I want to hopefully, he'll display it.
He'll take good care of it.
Yeah, I'm sure.
I'll put it right.
Oh, chickens.
Oh, she's basically...
Don't attack me, please.
Why would the chickens attack?
Nice.
Oh, you need corn to be tamed.
You know you're being attacked by all the creatures of the
forest.
Yeah.
Anyone got any corn?
Apparently we can tame these chickens.
I have corn seeds.
I have roasted corn.
You have roasted corn.
Yeah.
I'm going to eat.
Maybe we can tame those chickens.
Oh, it looks so nice in here, Phoebe.
I love what you've done with the place.
Thank you.
I stole those candlesticks, too.
I was like, this would be nice.
This would be nice to have for myself.
I see you guys.
Wait, did you not realize that this was the place that we
were at?
You were just standing there, Mickey.
Guys, my directions are awful.
I've had to go off the map this whole time.
Okay, right, okay.
Oh, I love the deity statue.
That's lovely.
Thank you.
Can you give me a...
tour Phoebe give me tour the house yes so here's the
entrance I have oh my stolen candles here guys oh that was a
gas are you good I got lettuce let's go hold on I will make
what we need for our our little guy what do we need for a
farm um oh sleep in a bed Vicky okay I will that'll make me
spawn here won't it I don't remember I'm gonna figure it
out.
Like, can we make a hole or something?
Let's see.
Farmer's Workbench.
I got it.
I'm making it right now.
And once I build this...
Once we make this...
Any stone pipes?
Yes.
What do you guys call your bed?
Rome.
Rome?
because it wasn't built in the day.
Oh, no, no.
For my IKEA bed that took forever to build.
We also have a builder's workbench, too.
Yay!
Wait, what is this build?
Whoa.
My gosh.
Look at this.
Oh.
Whoa.
What is this?
It's a green crystal.
Glowy stuff?
Is it glowing?
It is glowing, right?
How do I...
It feels like it is.
Oh, are you okay?
Yes, I was having ladder issues.
Okay, yes, I'm back.
I go up and I see you going up and down the ladder.
Grow.
Yeah, yeah.
That's lovely.
Lovely.
I'm going to plant the sun.
flowers too oh yes somewhere oh it's so atmospheric a nice
little house in the in the sunset look oh beautiful it's
beautiful oh we love this this house we stole i'm happy i
get to yeah it's fun i mean i'm so happy i get to wake up
and go to sleep to this view with you guys every day.
From the house we stole.
There's only two beds as well, right?
Can we like, at least share the best one points even if we
can't all sleep?
Well, actually, we can...
I can make a bed roll.
Actually, I have just enough to make a bed roll.
Oh, yeah, if you don't mind.
I didn't, I didn't...
Oh.
Yeah, I don't mind.
Fili, you want to fire?
Okay, you're okay.
I, uh...
Sorry, that was the flame of my love for...
Passion.
Yeah, put me in the middle.
Put me in the middle.
I am but a maid.
I deserve the floor.
No, that is so sad.
This is my bed roll.
I already claimed it.
You claimed it.
Okay, we sleep.
We can rotate.
Look at us guys.
Look at us.
no actually guys this is my very japanese futon so um i i
don't sleep in an in a normal bed i need a futon yeah i need
a futon can i can i see your guys's bed name oh i can't oh i
want i think if you try to sleep in it what did you name oh
wait hold on i'll try and say the respawn no it just says
the respawn point has already been claimed oh yeah oh well
what is yours called you guys won't get Um, it was dream of
Wario's ass land.
Wait, I need to be in there.
Let me head.
There are other entrances to Wario's ass land.
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to rename mine.
What?
Don't destroy it.
Hold on.
Mito, why are you destroying your bed?
So I can rename mine.
It's taking a second.
What did you name yours anyway?
Just mince spawn?
I named it the maid that deserves the floor.
Oh no!
Mito!
Mine is dream of Waluigi's Ashland.
Damn.
Pretty flat, but okay.
if that's what i'm sorry oh i love oh he's a skinny legend
skinny legend my my skinny legend is luigi but why have
luigi when you can have his his really eccentric brother
you're still real for that i said matt on twitter that mario
had a personality of wet cardboard and for some reason it
took off and i was a bit like um i saw that you're so real
for saying that he kind of does real real truth real truth
all right luigi on the other hand very very good character
in my opinion all right lettuce come on i know that you're
gonna grow well minta you must be always hanging out with
luigi right in luigi's mansion i know i'm stalking that guy
yeah Yeah.
All right.
No.
It's like passing the first Luigi's Mansion game.
The other one's fun.
You guys know.
I've never played them.
I think I played three.
It was good.
Yeah.
I think Luigi's Mansion is one, like, in my opinion, one of
the best Mario games.
I like them.
There are no good Mario games.
No, I'm just kidding.
Oh, just kidding.
I hate that guy.
I hope he dies.
Mario Sunshine kind of good though Kind of great actually I
love a good bit of Mario Kart I'm jealous of everyone
playing that Mario tennis game Oh yeah Looks fun Phoebe
you're blinking a lot Are you okay Am I blinking more than
usual Shake it out Shake it out Shake it out.
Shake it out.
What are we shaking out exactly?
Everything.
All of our feelings.
All of the feelings.
Yeah.
Where do you guys want to go?
And the lice.
The lice.
Let's have a look at the map.
Okay, what we got?
There's a big red forest.
There's a blue...
What is the blue forest?
The blue forest is kind of scary, but we can go.
Okay.
I mean, I'm down.
I'm down to the scary blue forest.
We can go through the red forest before going to the blue
forest.
So you can see both.
Nice idea.
Incrementally...
The knuckles forest and the sonic forest.
Wait, am I going the right way?
Oh, oh, oh, what are you?
What are you?
Oh, they're piggies.
You want an egg?
Oh, my God.
They're highland pigs.
Oh, eggplants.
Oh, my gosh.
They're so cute.
Why are they, like, I don't think I've experienced this kind
of cute aggression.
in a while you might like this guy too uh vicky over here oh
yeah i have like no health where are you guys oh i'm trying
to can i eat raw meat you can't i think which guy oh i like
him he's cute press f to interact oh you're very sweet what
does he want what does he want wait hold on oh look Minto,
look, one for you as well.
I know!
What a thrill.
Will he, can I tame him?
I don't know.
It is one for you.
Can I tame you?
No, I can't tame him.
Is he chasing after this guy?
He might be.
No, they're like companions or something.
Yeah, he's like, pick up blood leaf.
Okay, I'm gonna try and eat raw meat.
I'm gonna need to eat something.
Gonna try and eat raw meat.
Nice.
If you really want, I can make a campfire.
Yeah, we can make a campfire.
Um, I could eat moss.
I could eat a stick.
I could eat green crystal shards.
Here's some corn on the cob.
Here's some corn.
There you go.
Oh, thank you.
Eat that.
Thanks.
A pile of skulls.
He's a bit hungry again.
Why meet skewer?
Oh, meet skewer.
Oh, thanks, guys.
Hmm.
Alright.
It's Vicky Fee.
Yeah.
Vicky need this little snack, guys.
Honestly, true to real life.
All right.
Okay, I think I see the area.
Hold on.
I'm scouting.
Yes.
I do see.
There's like this one really annoying guy in the marsh that
I hate.
So, I don't see him.
Just one guy because you're up.
Where are you guys?
Where'd you go?
I don't know.
I found Phoebe.
Oh.
I'm up here.
Turn around.
Oh, hello.
Yeah.
Hi.
I hate this.
Oh, don't fall where I did.
Oh.
And then she did it.
You know what?
I think you need shoes, Missy.
That's why you're getting...
Yeah.
That's why.
No, no, no.
you know if we're touching grass it needs to be like the
pure touching grass i want my toes to feel the feel the
grass you know yeah yeah lush underfoot i'm swimming i'm
swimming what's this guy a pike can stuff attack you in the
water or it's the guy i hate he's right in front of us i
don't know i've never had anything attack me yet in the
that's the guy you hate yeah this is the guy i hate he's
like a little oh no no no no no no no i hate you we will
avenge you swamp cryptic yeah he's icky he's like the thing
that came from the swamp yes he did he didn't even have any
good drops or anything i know he's so lame so what's your
history with that guy why do you hate him there was one time
there was one time I was doing something and he just kept
respawning on top of me and I almost died.
Don't laugh.
It's my trauma.
You're right.
That's insensitive of me to laugh at your trauma.
Whoa, we're red right next to blue.
These are such pretty mushrooms.
Oh, it's so pretty.
Yeah.
Wow.
My mortal energy.
Oh, to live in a place where the leaves actually turn red.
red in the fall be careful of bear oh oh that's oh not again
again you're so right wait where are you guys uh okay i'm
going the wrong way where are you did you go to the to the
no no i i found oh i see you i see you there's a place over
here we could probably overtake i think it's goblins oh oh
what's us the house the house renovators oh actually i don't
i don't know if we could take this guy i don't know we could
try oh he looks kind of looks kind of chunky what are you
what is you what was that oh red cap and i have a blood cap
leaf he's just standing here he's got nothing he's not doing
anything wait i'm gonna take his uh maybe he doesn't care
projectiles oh i do oh what just Did he just throw something
at us?
He, like, tried to bomb rush you or something.
Ow, ow.
Oh, the spikes hurt.
Yeah, don't stand on the spikes.
Wait, where'd he go?
Where did he go?
They just run away.
Were we too intimidating?
I'm going to go with that.
You were too intimidating.
Yeah, probably.
Yeah, yippee!
Woo!
Yeah!
Let's go!
Woo!
Wait.
I can take him.
I can take this.
Craft.
Lost civilization abroad.
a year yeah i'm taking it i'm taking it yeah i'll climb the
statue oh he's got the yeah they've got statues i can climb
on top look guys look at me oh baby look at me wait hold on
you look so you Yeah!
Whoa!
Let's go!
With the sun kicking out behind you?
Whoa!
I can see up your skirt!
Oh, oh!
Excuse me!
No, no, no!
Very naughty.
It's perfect tickling, tickling opportunity.
Tickle, tickle, tickle, tickle, tickle, tickle.
I'm gonna have some raw meat above my...
Please cook it.
Please cook your beef.
oh they have sashimi of like everything i'm sure it's fine
right they have the worst sashimi too have you guys ever had
the chicken sashimi no oh i've never had no i've not i had
it once and i was very scared i mean apparently it's safe
but like everything i've ever been told pointed to it not
being safe so i was like yeah wow we can just get all these
metal spike traps i know we can make peace out why did he
leave all the i mean there's not really anything here i'm
not gonna lie yeah i'm looking for something useful oh i
found an apple guys i can finally eat something normal oh
it's so exciting finally i'm taking this statue as well yeah
take the other statue berries yeah eat them eat those
there's a little cottage over here i'm gonna go check it out
cottage yeah abandoned cottage oh uh oh it's so cottage yeah
it's cute actually so oh that's so sweet oh there's some
lettuce in here oh oh this is a quaint little cottage it
might have a basement sometimes there is a spider outside
but hopefully that's fine that's very quaint indeed isn't it
little patched roof.
Yes.
Are you fine?
You said that sometimes they have basements?
Like, so if we dig down.
Yeah, you could check.
My diggy thing is nearly, um, dead because...
Oh, yeah.
I dug all the way to you guys before.
Oh.
I mean, there's, like, stones under there.
Probably not, then.
Don't worry about it.
Oh, it's just less effective.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
It doesn't actually break, but you can, I wouldn't wreck,
you could just throw it.
Yeah, you could just throw it away and make a new one,
though, because I gave you some guys some pretty.
There's pumpkins.
Oh!
Venom sack.
Oh.
Pumpkins.
Pumpkin.
That's not a little fairy circle there.
Do you guys, Did you guys play Minecraft much?
I've been playing it more now that I'm playing with Nini.
Yeah, you have been.
Oh, yeah, how's that going?
It's so mysterious.
We found Squonk!
Well, kind of, sort of.
Found Squonk, Squonk from Pennsylvania.
It's a it's a cryptid.
And that's my Oshi cryptid.
She's like a pig that's crying all the time.
My Oshi cryptid.
I didn't know he was in Minecraft, but he's been in
Minecraft.
Skunk.
When he's in Minecraft?
Well, his tears have been, so he's been leaving a trail.
So you'll find him.
Someone's been stealing our llamas.
We're gonna find him.
Someone's been stealing your llamas!
I built my very first nether portal.
Whoa.
I know someone's stealing my llamas.
And right now they're trapped in the nether, so we have to
build another nether portal some time to take them out.
Oh.
That's a lot of work.
It's been a time.
Yeah, it has been a time.
Yeah.
Well, good luck with your detective work on finding the
llama thief.
Yeah, who could have been stealing them?
That's kind of scary.
What if there's a third person on the server?
There's a third person on the server.
Wait, there is?
Yeah.
They're mysterious.
They're very mysterious.
Wait, what?
Yeah.
Hero blind?
I know, right?
I was like, no.
Lord Finger?
That's what people always say.
They're always like, oh, is this Lord Finger?
And I'm like, I don't think Lord Finger could concoct a plan
like this.
I don't believe.
Don't you give him too much credit.
Yeah, I give him too much credit.
I think the spider might be coming after us.
Why?
Could you not do anything to you?
Yeah.
I was okay with you being outside the house.
The way they crawl up, curl up is so icky.
Oh, you're green.
You're green.
Oh.
Oh, I don't want to be green.
You're either poisoned or smelly.
Oh, don't worry.
It's gone away now.
Green is good.
The smelliness is gone.
Do we want to go see the blue?
I don't want to be smelly green though.
Yes.
The blue forest.
The blue.
The red, the blue.
The green.
Oh, there's another cottage here.
Huh.
Oh.
Made you guys go?
Cute.
Oh, there's also a guy.
Oh, here, I'll come and find you.
Oh, opposite way, okay.
I'm doing really good with my map reading, guys.
I'm proud of myself.
I believe in you.
Yeah.
Oh, there's nothing here.
I'm glad we have that.
Oh, wait, wait, BB.
Oh.
Stand here.
Knock, knock, knock.
Oh, who is there?
Hello.
Hi.
Well, how did you...
Oh, hello, hello.
Are ghosts like vampires where they can't enter your house
unless you give them an invite?
No.
Or do they just enter however they want?
It's okay, fairies just vent.
They're small enough too.
Yeah.
I saw Phoebe vent.
Oh, a bear trap!
Let's disarm that.
But does that mean there is a bear?
There's always a bear.
Oh.
True, there's always a bear.
I think a blue is over here.
I wonder if this place has a basement.
I didn't see one.
I don't think so.
Yeah.
Okay.
I think this way.
Yeah, this way.
What are these?
What are these glowing mushrooms?
Orange glowing mushrooms.
They look definitely shakety.
Eat, I'll grab some of those for later.
Grab them, grab them.
Everything is potential food for you.
Vicky needs to be in the kitchen.
Yeah, you know, I need my sustenance.
Making such cool concoctions.
Ooh, violet glowing mushroom.
This place is so cute.
cute we could build a house here if you guys wanted to i
would like that might be kind of scary is that it's spooky
though oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh get that bear
away
then set to versus bear round two okay we did it nice good
job this time around we're stronger Yeah.
Good job, guys.
Wow, the trees are so cute.
Yeah.
They're curly.
It's very cute here.
I just heard a squail.
Yeah, what was that squeak?
He's right here.
He'll be fine.
What'd you find?
Oh, my God.
He's so cute.
Phoebe, you need to see this girl alone.
Talk to me.
What do you want?
Wait, can he wants freedom?
Yeah, why can't you give him nuts?
What the heck?
Oh, where did you go?
Wait, are you running?
Trapper.
Are you running?
Actually, I wonder.
Yeah, maybe I can just put blocks around him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're too fast.
Wait.
Oh, are red squirrels more common in America, are they?
They're still kind of rare.
Or what?
Like in the UK, most of them are...
Like, most of the squirrels in the UK are grey squirrels.
Oh!
But in some places, they have more red squirrels.
I think grey is more common.
I feel like ours are...
Oh, what were you gonna say?
This guy's a little rare guy.
A brown?
Yeah, I see, I think I mostly only see...
At least in California.
Oh!
No!
The spider's going after the squirrel!
No, spider!
No!
Bad!
Yeah.
Yes.
Tell him.
Take care of him.
Yeah, we told him.
Yeah, we told him, guys, don't worry.
Now he's gonna love us, right?
Well, you're gonna love us.
We should have kept him alive so he could tell his friends
not to be around these parts.
Oh, true.
You love us now.
You love us.
If I see you in these parts again.
Little life.
Where are you taking us?
What a cutie.
Are you just running from us?
I think he's just running from us, but he might lead us to
his home.
and we'll see his little squirrel babies.
Squirrel babies!
Oh, and smaller squirrels.
He's down here.
He's jumping everywhere.
Take us to your leader.
Yeah.
He's giving us the... actually he's giving us a tour of the
place.
He's like, yeah.
And then there's this place.
Yeah, this is the...
This is the DMV.
Oh, no, he's just so cute.
He's so cute!
What do the bunnies want?
Do they want anything?
Um, I haven't seen one since that one area where you can't
do anything.
Hold on, yeah, they're here, they're here.
What do you want?
Carrots!
He wants a carrot!
Oh my gosh, there's a...
Oh my god, wait, I found my new favorite.
Have you guys seen the boar?
The boar is so cute!
Oh, what the flavor?
Wait, I have pumpkin!
That's an alive bear!
Oh, are you okay?
It's an alive bear.
Oh, it's an alive bear.
Vicky, take those and tame him.
Okay, where'd you go?
I'm coming after you, Phoebe.
Where are you?
Am I going the right way?
Where'd he go?
I'm checking the map.
Oh my god!
I'm heading towards you!
Where are you?
Oh, are you in the water?
Hi.
I am.
Oh, I think he stopped following you.
confused you can come over here come over here you're okay
you're okay yeah he's confused oh yeah are you guys good
yeah but i want to watch you tame the i'm here i'm trying to
find more balls i think i found some more over there okay
that ball yeah all right here i have something for you wait
i want to oh here you okay i want to watch hello hello sweet
one oh my gosh there's a baby
Come here!
Come here, please!
I wonder how you give it to him.
Oh, Jack, hello.
Bro.
Stop running!
Oh my god.
How do you give it to him?
Do you throw it on the ground and they eat it?
What?
Oh?
He's not moving anymore.
Oh, he's looking at you.
What's happening?
Hi.
Oh, he's sniffing me.
Wait, did you give it to me?
Oh, I saw a heart.
I saw a heart.
He loves you.
Oh,
my God.
He's so cute.
Oh, he's following me.
Baby.
How do I give it to him?
I think you did.
Do I need to do anything?
I did.
Oh, he's just sniffing now.
If you take it out of your hand, does he still follow you?
Does he still follow you?
If I take it out of the hand.
Oh, he does.
He does.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, he likes you.
Let's take you back to our house.
What about the babies?
What about them?
What about the baby?
He's not following.
Oh, he's not following.
No, no.
I think you gotta do it again.
But he's not running anymore.
Oh, press after pet.
You can pet.
Oh, my God.
You can pet them after you tame them.
You can pet them.
Oh.
I like the little baby that's staring in the background.
He's over there.
They also like this.
Oh my god, he's so cute.
Hakuna Matata.
Yeah.
What a wonderful phrase.
There are mere cats in this game.
Really?
Yeah.
We can find both of them.
Bring them back.
Oh, look at them.
Reunited.
Baby.
Oh, they're so cute.
What should we do?
Should we bring them home?
Yeah, we could.
Do I have to keep the pumpkin out?
Alright.
I think you might want to.
Let's see if I keep the pumpkin out.
Do they follow?
What about the other baby?
Wait, this baby.
There's one more baby.
Oh, do we need to get the other baby as well?
Okay, Chutmante.
Do you have enough pumpkin?
We can't leave this baby behind.
Come here, little sweetie.
Oh, he's running.
No, don't run away!
Oh, oh, there's a bear.
There's a bear.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, my God.
little ones please don't die okay oh my god no we must we
got him no run fast the little ones we got him they're good
now where's the other little baby oh no the other baby's
been separated oh no don't worry i can see it i can see it
oh you found it i just watched a bear emerge from the not
running away stop running away please stop running away oh
my gosh where did he just jumped like five stories at once
what is this baby doing uh he's in here there's another bear
there's they're stuck I'll help them oh sorry no no no oh
there's another bear oh oh oh my god um no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no okay he's safe he's safe you're good he's safe
oh oh they go Oh my god, that was the scariest moment of my
afterlife.
Guys, guys, I might have messed it up with the other baby.
I think I might have hit it by accident.
Oh no!
Wait.
Wait, they're finicky.
Well, here's your...
Come collect.
Here's your big guy.
Everybody's gone.
Where'd they go?
I'm with the big guy.
I'm just making sure he doesn't go anywhere.
I think the other guy's gone.
baby is done for okay i'm gonna come back to where you guys
are your one baby's following you though
who's this one i think this is the one you were trying to
get right yeah i didn't mean to don't be mad at me come on
man nah he's he's mad he's like in mad yeah okay i'm gonna
go back to where phoebe is yeah so what's the sparkly things
in the water They are Azure Kelp.
Is your one baby following?
I don't know if he is.
Oh, there he is over there.
So cute.
Look at his eyebrows.
They're so big.
He's got big old thick eyebrows.
You got to come back with us, Thor, please?
Can we get, like, fences and stuff?
Yeah, we can make fences.
Nice.
All right.
I've got the pumpkin, so can you guys tell me where the heck
our house is?
Yeah, I will take this home.
It's in this direction.
Yay!
Is he still falling?
I think he's kind of slow.
Oh, he's just kind of slow.
Yeah.
We'll take it slow.
We'll take it easy.
What happened to the other baby?
Oh, they're both falling, I think.
Okay, good.
Oh, they're both falling.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Um, are they falling?
Are they?
Oh, no, he's coming.
He's coming.
I see him.
I see one baby.
There's a baby.
Oh, come on.
Okay, hold on.
I need a real quick.
I need a free.
I need to free him.
He's so cute.
That's what I was trying to do earlier.
He was, like, stuck on a tree on the rocks.
Yeah.
Is he too chunk?
No, no, he's okay.
He's okay.
He was stuck in the tree, but he's good now.
Alright, nice.
Oh, he's running.
Why is he running?
Oh, where is he going?
Why are you running?
Why is he running?
Hey, why are you running?
Why are you running?
Go to your mom.
Wait, are you running?
Well, he's kind of running back home, so...
I tried to wave the pumpkin in front of their face.
It didn't work.
Oh, wait, where are you going?
Where are you going?
He was going in the direction of home.
Yeah, he was.
I'm trying to lead him this way, this way.
Yeah, that way.
There we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh.
I think if we hit him, he gets upset.
There's lots more pumpkins here!
Oh!
Yay!
Oh, I think my inventory is full.
Maybe if one of you guys try to like...
Where are we?
We're heading home.
It's okay.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You want to try on these guys?
Oh wait, they need the eggplant.
That's right, they need the eggplant.
No, no, where are you going?
Where are you going?
Stop, stop, stop.
No, no, no.
Stop, stop.
This way.
Why are you running?
This, yeah, that way.
This way.
I tried.
I tried so hard to get him to do the pumpkin.
He's not.
He's not taking it.
And then where's the baby?
Oh, no.
I don't know.
Guys, I think we might have.
I think we might have lost them.
Including this guy.
They're just too free-spirited.
I think so.
They are not... Oh!
Oh!
He died!
Why did he die?
I think he drowned!
He drowned!
No!
Oh, this is tragic.
Well, guys, look.
We must eat in his honor.
You know?
We must what in his honor?
I have a berry.
Oh, yeah, I ate some berries in his honor.
You could eat his raw meat.
Yeah.
This is just like that part of the Minecraft story.
What?
Apparently there's like a part where a guy, where a piggy
dies and then the guy, he just turns into pork.
Oh no!
That's too sad.
He's just like a part.
So wait, what happened there?
We hit him by accident.
He got, he got annoyed and then went in here and drowned.
Okay.
The trauma was too much for him.
Yeah, he couldn't take it anymore.
Oh, gosh, this guy scared me.
Who is this guy?
Do we want to go home and sleep?
Yeah, we might run into some nighttime creatures.
They're pretty spooky.
I'm not going to lie.
Uh-oh.
Is it like Minecraft where all the monsters come out at
night?
Well, it seems like they're alive during the day, too.
Yeah, but there's different ones at night.
They're kind of freaky.
Oh.
Oh, some of them are dead.
dead here this is where some were killed oh there's one guy
over there i see him oh oh don't don't touch these because
they hurt you oh wait oh yeah here this is a bad guy he's
like a void larva yeah oh here he comes oh they're nasty
yeah get him yeah get him i'll take the essence of the void
a couple of seconds after they die.
I don't.
Oh, ouch, ouch.
Oh, no, little one.
Stop.
Ow, please stop.
I don't want to hurt you.
It is my favorite little guy that I had to smack again.
I think the most formidable fault are these bushes.
I know.
Oh, there's lots of sunflowers here.
Cool.
Oh, there's a lot of sunflowers.
Woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo.
Hi, bro.
Kill him.
Get him.
Yeah.
Oh, did he drop some money?
What was that?
Oh, no.
Oh, they took back their house.
Money.
Huh?
Yeah, they took back the house.
What?
Well, I guess you just have to take it back then.
Take it back.
Oh, oh.
Well, if I die here, um, oh, shoot.
How big?
We customize this place for me on our own!
That's my anime figure!
The article!
Yeah!
Oh, I'm gonna die.
Oh, shoot.
I'm gonna die.
Um...
Hey!
Oh, are you okay?
Minto.
It's okay.
Oh, I'm Minto.
Oh no.
I'm right here.
Oh, because I...
Where I spawned.
Or, you know.
It's all good.
Let's just get myself.
Oh, jeez.
Where are you guys spawning in from?
I thought that maybe because we put some torches or the
torches are here they would be leave me alone hey maybe we
need more torches maybe is that my stuff down there yeah we
can sleep oh yeah we go to sleep we sleep yay guys oh my Oh
my god.
We claimed our house back.
We did not let them do that to us.
Claimed our rightful space.
I cannot get up the ladder.
Hello, Minto.
Oh, he's just trapped here forever.
You're going to watch you dry.
Minto!
Oh, I think I made it.
I made it.
You made it.
Yeah, I made it.
Yay.
Woo-hoo!
Thank you guys for the gift of memberships on the Den Thank
you!
Thank you!
Alright guys, a new day!
What do we explore now?
A new day has dawned us.
We could go anywhere your heart is eye.
Let's have a look at that map.
We went to the blue forest.
Oh, there's like a desert out to the right with some like
ruins.
What is Q?
Oh yeah, that's your ult.
That's what I did!
When I, like, jumped in the air with the thing, I'm like,
pooh.
I thought you were just really good or something, but that's
cool.
You're pretty good.
We have an ult.
We could go to the desert.
It's very scary.
I will warn you.
It'll be fine, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
Let's go!
Wait, before we go, I do want to see if I can make us...
armor yeah i want to see if i can someone told me i can i
can go down the ladder i can go down the ladder get books i
can do it you can go down the ladder i can go down
apparently i don't know do it maybe it's just i believe in
you i believe in you okay why is this so difficult oh i did
i did i did it yay i think you took my uh my something's uh
Phoebe my thingy I did my something my inventory was full
suddenly oh is it this furnace yeah yeah hold on I'll grab
it in just a second I needed to get rid of some stuff thank
you here you go thank you oh look who needed the corn again
we came the chickens the chickens the chickens yeah oh wait
these carrots can I use them for the bunnies oh yeah you
could There is bunnies nearby.
Oh, there's only, you only have two carrots though.
Um, can I take some mature corn?
I have 19 carrot seeds.
Oh, you do.
Why can't I also have some seeds?
There you go.
Oh, I see that was mint oak doing those seeds.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
How am I planting seeds?
Oh, don't worry.
Sorry.
No, I was just really confused because I had a, I had a and
block and I was like, wow, how did I plant seeds with that?
That's cool.
No.
All right, nice.
Oh, we have the statue of the ancient knight.
Add him to our Oshikats.
Oh, yes.
Oh, he looks so good.
I'll get my pen light out for them.
What can I use to...
I'll just use the beach.
Beach, beach!
I put the corn in the um in the chest next to the farm if
anybody oh thank you and the lettuce I already took one of
each is that okay yeah of course awesome I'm just I'm gonna
try and make us some armor thank you do any of you guys like
have stuff in your inventory that you're like how the heck
did that get there?
I've got some softwood roof in my laundry.
Some salt.
Do you know how that got there?
Sometimes enemies will drop salt.
Yeah.
Oh, is that it?
Okay, no.
59 cobblestone.
I know how I got that.
Yeah, you know how you got that.
I think we all know.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I need some light hide.
Okay.
I guess I took some metal spikes traps oh yeah i have those
one thing that's nice about this game is if you put stuff in
like a chest and you're trying to craft something it'll you
don't have to have it in your inventory it'll like see that
it's in the chest nearby and it will take it from there yeah
oh no i don't want to eat these mushrooms i want to plant
them why don't you want to eat them i want to try the the
glowing mushroom blue something looks definitely safe this
is part of maybe food trying is part of like an essential
part of your content here yeah oh I can't eat them
apparently I just tried oh my god Vicky I got you some good
snacks to try yes please good snacks oh my gosh I got you
some stuff to try Next time I see you.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where's...
I just grabbed some Trader Joe's stuff.
I see.
I thought you meant, like, right now.
I also got Trader Joe's stuff.
You also got Trader Joe's stuff?
Wait, I was like, I definitely want to bring some snacks.
Did you...
I'm so excited.
Did you get Vicky a bag, also, one of the Trader Joe's bags?
So, yes.
Me too.
But, like, I don't...
What is Trader Joe's?
It might not be the same one, though.
It's like the mac and cheese one.
Mac and cheese.
There was a mac and cheese one.
Well, so Trader Joe's is like a slightly bougier, like,
grocery store market that we have here, like a grocery store
chain.
Yeah, it's like kind of organic and, yeah, and like,
healthy, yeah.
But the bags.
Apparently, the tote bags, they're just supposed to be
reusable.
so you don't like so you can be equal friendly but you're
like oh trader joe they're being traitor oh traitor joe like
he done something wrong traitor what did joe do what did joe
do to be a trader traitor trite and joe's i'll dare you
betray us like but yeah the bags like trend are trending in
japan like they they're popular really yeah it's really
strange $5 reusable bag is like 90 bucks over there or
something.
What?
Almost, that's crazy.
Yo.
Yeah, my housemate's brother had to take a work trip to
Japan to visit his like Japan branch co-workers and he was
like, oh yeah.
I need to get this Trader Joe bag.
I need it.
So we kept, he like tasked us with getting it for him.
I can't unhear Trader.
Every time we went, they were all sold out.
Trader.
I'm sorry guys it's it's my brain rot I love the show the
traitors it's like literally like one of my favorite things
ever yeah it's so good it's like among us what is what's
among us but it's like among us in real life oh I've heard
it I've heard of it yeah it's so good oh I watched like all
the different series pretty much oh there's a guy living in
our basement oh my god uh yeah is he blare witching don't
worry about him uh he's just walking around with the with
the with the torch i mean could be now he's trying to attack
me okay sorry you have to die um oh there was a chest down
here oh nice where'd he go he put moss in it wait that might
be me i might have done that sorry okay let's see um
everybody uh yes vicky yes
oh does this mean i have to wear pants oh it might be pants
yeah oh that's that's okay don't worry i like i like going
pantsless in other games but that's okay someone in chat
said that the basement was traitor joe
that was him i thought he was a bro i thought he was he was
traitor bro but he was traitor bro yeah he's traitor um i
think my armor automatically equip if i picked it up uh no
you have to put it on but you can also you can toggle it
where you don't see it so you can wear it but you don't have
to look at it if you like your outfit How do you do it?
Um, on the side, where you see your...
When you go to tab.
Oh, yeah, you'll see it there.
Oh, I think I put them on.
You did!
Guys, I'm sorry.
The feet are no longer out.
But I am protected.
I just feel...
I felt bad that you were going to get splinters and stuff.
Yeah, I was a little worried about your feet.
Yeah.
Phoebe?
Here's your little hat.
That's so cute.
Oh, my little hat.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for our presence, Minto.
You can toggle it if you think it's ugly.
I will probably toggle it off.
I'm, yeah, there.
I want my flower to be visible.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah, sorry, guys.
I do kind of, I don't feel like me without my feet out.
I'm sorry.
No, I get it.
I get it.
You know?
I think the rest of this is going to take a while.
Something's just become part of your personality.
Yeah, just my high tail.
brand you know like yeah six six five exactly just having my
toes out i forgot about my username we didn't we see it
every time you do oh wait i didn't build that
um thank you minto for being so knowledgeable and making us
stuff yeah Ooh, wait!
Furnace?
Can I cook some meat?
You can cook some meat!
Oh my gosh, do I have any left?
Oh, I could roast some pumpkin!
No, okay.
Moine.
Put some iron ore on?
Sick daggers, guys.
Yo!
Ninja Minto!
Whoa!
Oh, you won't be able to get away.
That's crazy.
So cute and intimidating at the same time.
Wait, you couldn't put meat in here in the furnace?
I don't think I had any.
I think I ate.
It'll roll.
I guess that's just the way I roll.
That's fine.
There's a million meat here.
I want to see.
Does anyone...
What are you rocking?
Oh, you're rocking the sword.
Let me see if I can make you something better.
I'm just muting to cough.
No!
No, it's okay.
Vicky, I give with you.
Take whatever time.
Okay.
Yes, what do you give with me?
An iron sword.
Oh my gosh, the upgrade is insane.
Wow!
Yeah!
You look even more Vigil!
Whoa!
This is definitely my style.
Phoebe, I like your weapon, but if you want another one, You
like it?
You like it?
Are we ready?
You can save your resources for now.
Okay.
I feel like it kind of matches the vibe.
Like you made it out of a tree or something.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
With the flower cape and that.
You've got the vibes.
Shall we go to the desert?
Let's go to the desert.
Hey.
Hmm.
I guess I think we have to go back basically the way we can,
though.
like to through the course it started raining as soon as we
left the house storming that oh wait it's a clear day for me
two second storm yeah it's a clear day for me oh i'm stuck
in a tree oh bunny bunny ah big bunny i do technically have
the carrots but you could try what how will we get him home
yeah yeah maybe on the way back home yeah oh this is a big
Big pod.
Oh.
A big swamp.
Yeah.
What's underneath?
Let's go.
So, my swamp.
The swamp.
Stay out of my swamp.
I was watching Shrek 2 with my members the other day.
Who would be Shrek?
Who would be Donkey and who would be Puss in Boots?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
I love this.
I don't know.
Out of the three of us?
What do you mean to define that dynamic?
I know, right?
I feel like that's the dream team, right?
That's true, it's true.
I mean, you know, Shrek is green, so would that have to be
Minto?
Am I Shrek?
The Shrek?
I could be don't care.
That'll do, don't care.
I don't know.
That'll do.
I feel like I randomly sing annoyingly, and then And then
Phoebe, you know...
You can do the pussy boots like the face.
Yeah, yeah.
The piano.
Pian.
Yeah, yeah.
It's so rainy here.
Let's go!
We're going to the desert.
The desert.
So when you say that it's scary, like, what do you mean?
Or are we going to find out?
You'll see, yeah, you'll see.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
The game kind of, oh, has, like, difficulty spikes,
depending on the areas.
Oh, oh, yeah, I can climb.
Oh, my gosh.
We can climb these.
Huh?
Oh, my gosh.
You got it?
How do you climb?
You just, like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Breath of the Wild is...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um, um, um, do I need to press a button?
I need to climb.
Just hold, hold like the space bar when you're jumping.
Hold the space bar.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Sorry, it's a little, here.
Can you see?
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Now jump.
Move over a little bit.
I was also holding down shift as well.
I don't know if that helped.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, I did it.
Yay.
Thank you.
Oh.
guys oh oh we're good we're good i think so we're good we're
good yeah oh upskirt shy it's okay oh this is not quite the
desert but um oh yeah yeah the music seems to have gone kind
of sinister Steiner Lord Farquhud asked my chat.
Oh, my God.
Yes.
Absolutely.
I mean, who is he going to be, Prince Charming?
It's a knife fight.
Oh, my God.
He's, oh, nice.
I'm sorry.
I should have just let you, let you one be one him.
Look at the lizard.
Wait, can I tame you?
Can I tame you?
A lizard.
Oh, no.
You cannot.
Are you a cat?
Oh, if it might be unfriendly.
Wait, what is it?
Oh no.
Oh, it's so cute.
Oh, it's a bear cat!
It's a bear cat!
Oh!
What is it?
It's shooting out!
It's like pooping some food.
Oh my god, it's so cute.
Is it?
Oh, whoops.
Oh my god, so sweet.
He is so cute!
Can you tame him?
No, don't go down there.
We can go down there too.
No, I can't tame him.
Sun.
So cute, though.
Ooh, what are these flowers?
Press F to pick a blood rose.
A blood rose.
For quartz.
Oh my God, the warthog is so cute.
Hi.
He's so cute.
So sweet.
Are these peppers for cooking?
Mature chili.
Yeah, the mature chili.
When I was a young white dog!
Very nice.
What are these?
Antelopes.
Are we heading to the desert?
Ah, we're headed to the desert.
Nice.
Here we go.
Chat with the word fart ploy.
It's going to be fine, right?
Some of you may graduate, but it is a sacrifice I'm willing
to make that's so evil antelope hello those antelopes what
are they doing
they're still at it what are you guys doing are they okay i
think there might be some antelope action going on it's
called mother nature it is called mother nature what is that
how beautiful i wonder if this is a village another option
for steiner you know well steiner's always like doing doing
his best to make our dreams come true so fairy godmother i
guess is she evil fairy god i need a hero oh bad lands for
some bad lads here we go camel what do you want what do you
want dynamite wait what is that what is that i Coca-Cola?
Oh, what is that?
I can't tell.
Um, man, did you just... Did they just kick you?
Yeah, he just kicked me.
That is rude.
I'm not having that.
Phoebe, come look at these guys.
They're so cute.
Oh!
Sand lizard.
Oh, I'm coming.
This way.
They can be a little evil, but they're generally very cute.
Oh!
Hello, friends.
like fennec foxes yeah they're so cute and they have good
loot usually a little evil yeah they could sometimes like
try to hurt you but they're usually okay cute oh i like them
yeah oh they're sleeping um does anyone know what happens if
i turn off the skull of candles Ouch, I'm sorry.
Uh, do you want to...
I think they might be mad.
Do we want to...
Are they going to be mad?
No, you can probably turn it off.
Just turn it off.
They won't care.
I'm going to head up their ladder.
I'm sure they don't mind.
Yeah.
Hey, guys.
I don't mean any harm.
I'm just chilling up here.
I'm taking all their stuff.
I stopped pink and...
Flamingo?
Flamingo!
Do they care if you take their stuff, Minto?
No.
Okay, cool.
Then, itadakimasu.
Ouch.
What hurt me?
It's okay, because I will leave them with 59 cobblestone in
exchange.
Oh, Phoebe is going off on him.
Phoebe, where are you going?
I just want to see what's flying in the sky.
Oh, no, don't go to that guy.
Don't go to that guy.
I don't like it.
Don't get him.
He's a bad.
guy he's a bad guy he's a bad oh no i love me and mint are
like watching it from the tower i know in real time
if you're ever not sure about a guy i will let you know if
they're dangerous or not you're so right yeah it's okay i
should run it by you first No, no.
I love the way these little guys scratch their heads.
Which guys?
Where?
The way these little guys scratch their heads.
They're sort of like...
They're like, oh yeah, they're so cute.
They're so cute.
Phoebe, how far back are you?
She's probably back at home, right?
Home.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
So the desert's bottom right of here, I think?
Yeah.
It's just head south and you'll hit us.
okay yeah should we go meet her halfway it's okay i'll i'll
catch up with you so we can explore more of the mental can
you teach me the oh no can i teach you what squirrel it's
too late oh how to get down on yeah here here here here here
we have time we have time okay okay ladder lesson 101 okay
right so how do you position yourself in the correct place
to descend the ladder um i just uh i sometimes i'll start
falling and then i go back towards the ladder like i'll do
this okay what you want coin like that okay got it then you
just press down all right let me let me try that yeah i
believe in there i'm gonna get a good view i saw turkeys
turkey oh oh um
um okay one more one more time i believe we have time we're
waiting for phoebe to get here anyway so we might as well
okay one more time one more time guys right okay okay right
back up back up oh oh yeah you got it yeah you're good job
hey yeah hey yeah i'm gonna have a celebratory pumpkin for
that oh that's good so yes i probably need a bit more
actually have a new half health like half health too right
now yeah i'm just gonna keep eating where are you finding
mice feby in on the way to you i don't see you on the map
are you sure you're on the way to us you could just go south
right yeah just go south you can't eat the mushrooms plant
fiber that sounds edible No?
Okay.
Um...
I just keep finding new creatures.
And they're distracting me.
Apparently you have to cook the mushrooms.
Or... I wonder if it's like one of those, uh...
No, I'm back to my trusty snack of wheat.
Oh, wheat.
I got that too, actually.
Straight wheat.
I didn't know you could eat straight wheat.
Oh, tasty.
I feel like a horse, like eating oats and...
I know.
Porridge straight from the sauce.
That's as organic as it gets.
An armadillo!
Oh, you are close to me, mate.
We could come and find you.
Wait, where are you?
I don't see you on the map.
That's the only issue.
Girl, girl, like, all the way to the...
Yeah, girl.
Yeah, why'd you go so far over?
We can get you.
Um, I saw a little bit of...
I'm peeking out from the map.
Oh, okay.
And I thought that was you.
Oh, you're close.
You're close.
It's fine.
The map's not that big.
Just watch out for the flying bugs.
They're scared.
Oh, oh, no.
Oh, I didn't realize that was a hyena.
Oh, my gosh.
Minto, you gay.
Yeah, I'm good.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Don't hurt me.
Don't kill me, please.
Ouch.
I'm going to die.
Oh, nice.
I'm going to eat some weed.
Nice.
Oh.
You're running along.
Probably could have used some more, uh...
More and more armor.
I think you'll be fine.
Do you want that raw hyena meat or?
Oh, yeah.
Wait, did I grab it?
Oh, oops.
No, I grabbed it.
Do you want it?
No, it's okay.
Just run.
Oh, you got him?
Not yet.
That's chilling.
No ice.
Oh, wow!
Oh, that's a lion.
Oh, yeah, there's like a saber tooth.
And it's a...
Okay, I'm ready.
Let me see where she is.
Oh, you're so close!
You're so close!
We're just a mountain of sand away.
Yeah.
What did I say?
Why are people saying that I said that I'm gay?
What?
Did I say that?
Oh, you didn't know you could eat wheat straight.
Oh.
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
Yeah.
What is this?
Distracted.
Oh, it's a bug's nest.
Oh, this place is kind of icky.
Ew, ew, ew.
I don't like that.
Wait, do you want to go in?
Oh, mysterious tower.
I mean...
Yeah, it's filled with eggs.
Like these...
Let's take a look.
Yeah, yeah.
These are eggs and stuff.
Oh, it's getting...
It's making me like...
I know.
It's like...
I might die.
What happened?
Oh my god, where are you?
You won't die.
Ah!
We fell into the bug nest.
Oh!
Shoot!
Okay, I'm coming.
I'm coming.
Oh, God.
Oh, oh.
I'm trying to see where you guys are.
We're in a bugsness, yeah.
You're okay.
Oh, I'm about to die, Phoebe.
Oh, no!
No!
Bug'sness?
Why are you guys getting there?
Oh, because I was trying to block.
Oh, there's so many babies.
Oh, God.
Oh.
Oh, you're kind of cute.
They're cute, though.
the the insects themselves are not very cute yeah the big
guys they kind of suck yeah the babies are cute yeah the
babies are very cute oh ow ow these plants hurt okay I'm
gonna be outside eating some pumpkin okay because I have no
idea where you guys are I died I'm back at spawn all the way
back home to spawn oh I should have slept in one of those
beds dang it that's okay um um yeah we're fine are you like
a boss hello oh no that was just a bunch of babies all in
one place oh yeah I'm being followed by a hyena everything
is bad everything is happening you what is the point what is
what let's go guys I think I might be dead okay yeah are you
dead I can grab yourself oh wait will you spawned right
there why Hello!
I have no idea, but hello!
Are we going back to desert to get our stuff?
Yeah, we could go do that.
I miss my sword.
I'll try to guard your stuff.
Oh no, I still have my sword.
Yeah, you still have it.
Oh nice.
Be careful of...
Oh, is it just the stuff that's like, um...
Just the stuff that's in your inventory, not the stuff on
your hop bar?
I think it's more like it keeps stuff that is more important
usually.
It's kind of...
Yeah.
Um, Mendo, where'd you go?
Um, I just kept going straight.
Where are you at?
Okay.
Ooh!
Wow, this game is so pretty.
Pretty pretty.
I see you, I see you.
The colors of the sky are very nice.
Hello.
Quite pretty.
Are you still in the bug hole?
I'm in the bug hole.
Okay.
We're coming, we're coming.
We're coming, yeah.
and then when you die also you lose like a little bit of
durability on your stuff so ah okay so that armor and that
go it go it yeah yeah yeah as long as we don't run into one
of the flying guys i think we'll be okay i'm ready i'm ready
for them got my sword out me too pb how are you doing i'm
hanging in there every now and then a baby comes by and i
gotta squish it yeah They're very icky.
Phoebe's gonna become one with the bug family.
We're gonna get there.
And she's gonna be fully integrated.
Yeah.
One of the bug babies.
And then we'll just be friends with the bugs.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god, that guy scared the heck out of me.
I hear something.
Oh, ouch.
No, bro.
Yes, get him into, yeah.
Oh!
What was that?
Oh, it's one of these guys.
I don't know, but...
It's the swamp guys.
Sucks.
You're so icky.
Wait, Vicky, do you see that over where I'm looking?
The thing flying in the sky?
Oh my gosh, what is that?
Yeah, we have something flying.
We have to watch out for that guy.
Oh my god.
That looks intense.
Oh, was it some Elden Ring thing over there?
I know.
No, no, bro.
We'll just keep running through.
Was it the thing, what, Phoebe?
Was it the thing that killed me?
No, it's a nighttime-only creature.
Oh, that's terrifying.
Yeah.
Oh, God.
Are you okay?
Oh, no.
I'll be fine.
No, baby.
We're almost there.
I killed him in three hits.
We're fine.
Okay.
Yeah.
We're almost there.
He was just kind of big looking and scary looking.
He was not so bad.
I actually have no idea if we're almost there yet, but I'm
going to say that we are.
I think, oh, yeah.
You're not too, too far.
Yeah, we're not Too far.
We're not too far.
Let's go around this wall.
Oh, this gives me a chance to eat my bagel.
Ow.
Yeah.
You're brecky.
Wait, how do you...
Oh, I see.
In real life.
I was like, how do you make a bagel?
Make a bagel.
Sounds a heck of a lot better than all the old me.
I know.
I'm still poking at the bagel that I made an hour and a half
ago.
You've been eating bagels and I'm eating wheat and raw...
Yeah, wheat snags.
You didn't share that recipe with me.
I thought you were into it.
I thought you liked eating the raw wheat.
No, it's pretty good.
What is that?
Oh, a squirrel.
What the hell are you?
I'm a porridge, a porridge purist.
Don't need any of that milk.
Straight oats.
Oh, yeah.
Ah.
They call me a umamusame, you know?
You running fast.
Wait, there's somebody's stuff here.
Alright.
Is that yours?
It might be mine.
I think that's your stuff.
Yeah, that's where I...
That is where I died, yeah.
Um, okay.
Should I go get it?
Yeah, why not?
Who's whispering at me, bro?
Not right now.
Yeah, just leave them alone.
My stuff.
Oh.
Oh, they're surrounded by hyenas!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Yeah, I did.
Okay, just keep running, Minto.
Just keep running.
I'm gonna run.
I'm gonna run to where my stuff was.
Here I come.
I see you!
Yeah, I'm here.
Yes!
No!
Okay!
Don't worry, I'm coming.
I'm coming back.
Oh my god.
Ew, it's squishy.
I'll make it.
Don't worry.
Ew, it's so squishy.
Oh my god, where the heck was that again?
Okay, go straight.
There's people at our house.
Just so you know.
Oh, there are?
We'll deal with that when we get back.
Ah!
I might die.
Oh my god.
Is that hyena?
Yeah, you might want to kill that guy.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to bring him to you.
Okay, I killed one.
It's okay.
He got added to my memory.
Oh, good, good.
Okay, I'm gonna jump.
I'm gonna jump.
Ew, it's so squishy and disgusting.
Oh, I got it.
Ew!
Oh.
So you can stop the babies from...
You can stop the babies from spawning.
By killing the egg sacks.
Oh.
Yeah.
I have some news.
So we just pop all of these?
Some news?
I fell out of a tree and died.
Oh.
Vicky.
Wait.
Um.
I don't really know what happened there.
Are things okay for you?
Yeah.
No, things are dying.
Do you need anything?
Are you guys like still alive?
Should I come to you guys or should I wait here?
Well, we definitely need to.
a way out yeah we do need a way out yeah okay all right i'm
gonna attempt because it's kind of attempt number two yeah
attempt two oh i hear chewing right next to me me chewing
all right
um would it be better if we just let something kill us or oh
yeah we could just die and, um, get back to you, Vicky.
Oh, I mean, I've gone off into the darkness now.
I have no idea where I am.
Kill their, kill them, kill them.
They're evil, they're evil.
Ew, ew, kill, kill, kill, kill.
Unless we want them to kill us.
Yeah, their egg sacks are evil.
We'll destroy the whole colony.
They'll never...
No, no, no, no, no, no!
I believe in you guys who do it.
I won't let them have a...
You'll never reproduce!
Yeah!
Down with the bloodline!
The bug hole is very icky, isn't it?
It's so icky.
Yeah.
If I look too closely at the blocks, it makes my skin crawl.
I know, it's so gross.
Okay.
How did we fall down here?
How are we going to get out?
Hold on.
It was right here, wasn't it?
Yeah, okay.
I think so.
And I have some dirt, I guess.
I have some cobblestone too, so what we could do is, like,
build in one, two, three.
I think it's four that you can jump up without.
And then...
And then you could jump up that.
Two, three, four.
Like that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm waiting through the swamp, guys.
Oh, my gosh, hello.
No, thank you.
Oh, you guys have two.
Okay, good, good, good, good.
Cool!
Oh shoot, out!
Oh, you okay?
Yeah, I just fell, but it's okay.
Oh yeah, you can just climb up, yeah, climb up a...
The climbing in this game is much more generous and like...
than Minecraft.
I think I'm in the desert.
Are you?
Wait, let me see.
Yeah, I think so.
No.
Shoot out.
Not yet, and okay.
Nearly.
You're almost there.
Just keep going south.
Oh,
I only had one pumpkin.
Okay.
Let me just keep going.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you're almost...
Are we okay?
Oh,
out!
Freedom!
It even sounds so nasty.
It's like...
Yeah, bleh.
Oh, gosh.
A strange creature.
Where?
Ew.
Oh, this is one of the night guys, yeah.
It was, yeah.
Let me see if I can show you one of the...
In the essence of the void.
Let me see if I can show you one of the guys that's
floating, like the flying guys at night.
Okay.
We won't go too far, though, so...
I don't see where you are.
All right.
Go south, round...
Round five.
Wait, where are you?
Here we go.
Back at the house again.
Oh, Mickey!
Maybe we should go back home.
Yeah, let's go back home.
We're heading to you.
Okay, I will protect the house then as a first point of
call.
Thank you.
Yeah.
We finally got out of the bug hole.
Yay.
We're coming to you.
All right.
Here, I'll equip my torch so you can see me better.
Thank you.
Don't be a coward if you're going to shoot at me.
Come and shoot me in my face.
Phoebe, do you see that thing flying?
Oh, that's a scorpion.
Terrified.
It's like a squid.
Thank you.
It's pretty spooky.
That thing is scary.
Sky squid.
Oh, did you see the sky squid?
Yeah, oh, there he is.
No, it looks heckin' scary, bro.
Come give me.
Oh, my God.
Some kind of eldritch.
Come give me.
Sky squid.
Knowledge is like an Elden Ring boss.
He's literally just staring at me.
Come give me.
Come.
All right.
Phoebe.
take him on you attack because they only aggro on one person
oh let me take care of this rattlesnake we're gonna try to
attack it yeah okay i'm trying to come down did you die what
happened guys did you know you know on your compass at the
top right it has like your spawn point so right now at the
top it says dream of wario's asslands yeah a little to the
west Oh, beautiful.
I think he's stupid.
He's stupid.
Can he not come in here?
He's not attacking.
Wow, he just straight up died.
I killed him.
Let's go.
Did.
Wow.
Hello?
What did I grab?
Did he drop anything?
Yeah, I sent him to the void.
Oh, that's it.
Combined with my stack.
Oh, okay.
That's it.
Sometimes they drop rare stuff.
I thought they were going to have...
I thought he was going to have some...
super good drops.
Yeah.
Oh.
Ew, I hate these guys.
They're so icky.
I don't like that they just crawl like that.
Oh!
Oh, no?
Oh, I do, boo.
I'm fine.
I could take a few more hits.
Oh, wow.
I might have, like...
I might have one or two.
Oh, is that a bear?
No.
No, no, no, just run, just run.
No way.
Oh my god.
Not worth it, guys.
Just get out of there.
I got revenge!
Yeah!
Who are you?
Woohoo!
Was there anything in your inventory that you want me to
like, that you lost?
Nothing that I can tell.
If you want to get anything.
You know, whatever you want to get.
My...
It's full.
it's very full yeah don't worry about it yeah go ahead yeah
i'm gonna put some torches down oh shoot what is smacking me
go away go away oh president can i can i harvest a mature
carrot yeah of course oh mature carrot you think you own
this place but actually we own it yeah i got rid of some of
them yeah out of our house owned it to begin with yeah i
won't let you stay here i won't let you stay here no i love
i love the oshikatsu we've got going on here i know it's so
good it's so good um Bare.
Bears are the true enemy of densetsu, I agree.
Why do we always get ourselves in these situations with the
bears?
Nah, guys.
We got to be careful if we ever go hiking together in Japan.
I feel like they're, I feel like they're just gonna.
You know..
It's true.
They seem to just be...
Are there bears in the Japan forests?
Yeah.
yeah that's like an increase of bear attacks recently in the
countryside and stuff so you got really careful i thought it
was boars i didn't realize bears too were an issue oh yeah
bears bears yeah no my anka sensei like it's always like i'm
careful of the bears is he going outside everywhere is he
going out anytime i'm like yeah i'm i'm going hiking my
sensei's like the bears the bears clearly my man had a
situation happening yeah maybe i don't know
how you guys enjoying high tail so far i'm loving it i would
i would like to have at least one more adventure in the day
where i'm not getting killed by everything at night yeah
baby how's it coming getting back here yeah oh i see you
you're close you're close yeah You can do it, Phoebe, you
can do it.
We could go to the north instead because we went to the
south.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, sure.
You haven't checked it out.
In the north.
The north.
Ow, oh, oh, oh, god.
Bushes.
The bane of my existence.
Be careful, yeah.
In Minecraft, too, I always get caught in the berry bushes
and I've died.
They're evil.
They're so evil.
Oh, no, it's the guy that you hate.
It's your op!
I know.
He's worse.
I'm sorry.
I apologize for him.
It's okay!
You were on to apologize for him.
I understand now though.
Yes.
He's terrible, I see you because I literally can see you!
I can see you!
Swim, swim, swim!
Is he following me still?
No, no, he's not.
But he's gone.
Oh, I see another flying guy though.
I kind of want to go get him.
Okayiri!
Maybe he'll be...
Yeah, Okayiri!
Padaima!
Okayiri!
I'm happy to be home.
Are you okay?
You've died a lot.
Yeah, I was just looking at my map and I was like, what are
those things on the map?
Death day four, death day three, death day five, death.
Death, death.
Oh, so it keeps track of all of your deaths.
You can remove them if you don't want them anymore.
No, it's okay.
It's a good legacy.
It is a good legacy.
Yeah.
It reminds us of what they've taken from us.
We could sleep and let it go day and then we could adventure
one last time.
adventure to the north the north sounds like a plane no one
last sleep oh it's good to be back in bed
all right now it's the final day i'm gonna prove myself
prove myself i'm gonna i'm gonna go down the ladder oh yeah
yeah gonna be fine okay i'm trying okay i'll watch him up
here okay it's gonna oh it's gonna be fun okay yeah you're
on okay i can hear i can hear your keyboard
come on that's gotta be it right come on right okay oh Oh,
kind of!
I'll take it.
You didn't need the ladder.
True warriors.
Who needs ladders?
Don't need ladders.
Yeah.
Exactly.
All right.
I'm feeling I sort of want to be a Titan.
If you're a Quartz Titan, what kind of Titan are you going
to be, Vicky?
Oh, Wheat Titan.
Wheat Titan.
What about you, Minto?
I don't know.
I'm going to decide.
I'm going to think about it a little bit.
Maybe.
Oh, I brought this home, Phoebe.
To remind you of the hive.
Oh, no.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, Minto.
Those very considerate.
The memories.
The memories of being in the hive.
Wait, so that's some like honeycomb that you brought back.
Oh, I don't know if that's honeycomb.
Mm-hmm.
Yay, let's go to the north.
Is that fine?
Just to jump down there.
Yeah, you can land in the water.
There's water.
Woo!
So fine.
The north is kind of nice.
It's got like really...
If we can get to one of the icy areas, it's really cool
looking.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll probably die.
Go skiing.
Wee!
Ice skating!
Oh my god, I saw a TikTok yesterday of a place in Hokkaido.
And they're the only place that sells soft serve, but it
looks, it's in the shape of a cloud.
What?
Yeah!
We need to go.
We need to go!
Oh my god.
I want, I want cloud soft serve.
Yeah, it's so cute.
Like the way they like position the soft serve, they like,
it's in the shape of a cloud.
It's so cute.
That sounds so pretty.
Speaking of, I'm so excited to see what kind of...
Like, this is going to be my first time being in Japan
during, like, this season.
So, I've never, like, experienced springtime.
Well, winter?
Wheat Titan.
I don't know what it is right now.
Grab your snacks.
Wheat Titan.
Oh, get my snacks.
Get my snacks.
Let's go.
Need, you know, some good to be a good strong warrior.
You need some nice wheat.
Yes.
watch out for the wolves eat your bread you guys it makes
your bones and your muscles strong yeah wait does it sorry
if my voice is going a little bit by the way guys but i am
i'm having a good time oh it's okay this is our last
adventure yes don't push yourself too much yeah yeah for
real but the wheat the wheat warrior must continue it's so
much fun i know all right Here we go.
We could take on these goblins if you want.
Let's do it.
Hold on.
Let's get rid of this guy first.
There are horses.
We could try and find horses to ride.
Minto, you were so badass with those two blades.
Just like...
It looks real cool.
Oh, God.
Just die instantly.
He's terrorizing the animals.
He also has a wolf.
Oh, the wolf is terrorizing the animals.
The wolf is terrorizing the animals.
Oh, my God.
You!
Are you gonna get him?
Oh yeah!
Get him!
Yeah!
Are you guys seeing this?
Yeah, I'm seeing that.
Whoa!
Magic.
Usually they don't really have good loot here, but they're
kind of cool looking.
So I like the loot.
Oh, they have funky traps.
Yeah, get that carrot.
Get that carrot.
Oh!
eight oh
What is happening?
I don't think so I thought you would fall No We have to cut
the rows maybe Oh no, Phoebe no No, no, oh no, oh dear Oh my
god.
Vicky, no.
Minta, why are you just watching this and laughing?
You fell into the trap.
Oh my god.
How silly.
How do we get out now?
You can just dig.
This is a good question.
Okay.
Oh yeah, we can just dig.
Yeah, just dig.
Then Minta, hit you, Phoebe.
It's okay to worry about it.
Are you guys okay?
A little traumatized.
A bit frazzled.
Yeah, yeah.
Spit.
You know, it's not every day that you expect to be hung.
I know what?
I've never seen...
Drop to your death.
That was crazy.
I have like no health, so it's time for my wheat snack.
Oh, no.
But here, here, take this.
I found some wheat.
It's my last one, but you can have...
Oh, thank you.
Oh, I have some wheat also.
Here, here, here, here.
Don't worry, I've got 11 wheat left, guys.
Don't worry, it's okay.
Oh, thanks.
Yes, let's go.
And you can eat- Let's go.
Oh, I almost fell in.
Did you take it?
I took it.
Nice.
It's a...
It's compensation for them having dropped me.
Yeah.
Oh, watch out.
Six feet below.
The music in here is so funny.
Oh, I'm gonna steal all the care.
Dump, dump.
There's some more meat here.
Oh, I am so stupid.
I'm so stupid, I'm so stupid.
Whoa, I'm stupid.
Oh, sweet.
You got it.
What is this epic music?
Should I be scared?
No, it's just for the guys.
Oh.
Wait, so like, I have not heard...
I don't think I've heard music this entire time.
Wait, really?
Wait, what?
Yeah.
Is the game buggy for you, maybe?
Maybe.
I'm taking their torches.
I like quotes, Titan.
Look at my settings.
Music.
Is that 85?
Huh?
Yeah, it's like, Phoebe, you're telling me you can't hear
this tune.
I wish I could hear this tune.
All right, let's keep going north then, guys.
Yeah, see?
How me and Min are singing it is exactly accurate, by the
way.
It's low Yeah, it is kind of quiet The game sounds are still
going Oh my gosh Again Phoebe Phoebe What's happening You
faintly hear something in the background No Well let me just
put the little music volume up Even more then I guess No,
you could try Do you hear like the bird sounds and stuff At
least I can hear like Yeah, like my tools and stuff Okay
them no but i can hear the birds and stuff it could be also
like uh not in like a not everyone hears the same music at
the same time oh maybe yeah what's this wait wait wait oh
wow maybe i'll hear it next time oh hello is it the ball
from the other day Oh, no, wait, that one died.
Sorry, it's not that one.
Sorry, that was insensitive of me.
He reincarnated.
Yeah, maybe.
You are babies.
You trained them.
Oh, hi.
Hi.
Hello.
A little baby.
I only had one pumpkin, though.
Yeah, sorry.
I did have five, but eight more.
I think that's more important.
That's okay.
Yeah.
Your survival is utmost.
Yeah, exactly.
Thanks, guys.
Survival is key.
Snacking.
Snacking is the key.
Oh, wait.
I do hear some music right now.
Thank you.
Oh, okay, good.
So maybe it's just not everybody, like...
Oh, gosh.
Yeah.
Here's the same music.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, oh.
We could go to hell.
Oh, let's go.
Let's go.
If you look up on the map, you see north on the map.
Oh, is that hell over there?
Yeah.
I mean, that would be an epic, epic conclusion.
Yeah, exactly.
Let's do it.
We are definitely not trained for it, or suited up for it,
but that's okay.
We are trained for it, though.
That's okay.
In our spirit.
We're climbing up here.
Nice.
there's a there's a ride at disneyland called mr toad's wild
ride mr toad yeah it kind of scared me as a kid yeah you
literally you go to hell oh is that what the fire is yeah oh
why is everything on fire oh um um i'm trying to figure out
a way around because there's a bear down there and there's a
bear over there here let's go down this way why does bed why
does bed say den set to this tree oh i didn't mean to do
that i'm now in the tree and i can't see anything oh i
didn't even take that much damage by jumping down to be fast
oh you didn't okay no i saw the wheat oh damn oh the wheat
oh you're like a scarecrow at this point yeah exactly
yeah you literally so basically the ride is mr toad has a
crazy streak and who is mr toad i don't know i don't know
what's he from i guess his own thing from mr toad wait
where's vicky where do you guys go oh um we went down let's
see a little um it says that you're oh yeah just keep going
yeah keep going forward yeah there you are okay i'm coming
um Oh, Wind in the Willows!
Okay, yeah, I know that.
So he...
Did you guys read that as a kid?
No, I didn't.
But he like...
I didn't know it was Disney, but...
I didn't know either.
He's kind of crazy and he likes to drive and he keeps
getting into accidents and then...
So he's a reckless driver.
Yeah, and then...
Well, then he gets...
Isakai'd into hell.
Well, he...
Kind of.
I mean, he like gets sent to court and they're like, we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna you know you're gonna you
gotta do time and he breaks out of court by by um by um
driving and then he gets hit by a train and goes to hell
that's kind of crazy man that's the actual ride
wait so does he get out of hell no that's the end yeah
that's the end of the ride as you see damn that's it oh my
god he goes to hell yeah he goes to hell and that's the end
of the ride
cool guy man no he was causing his car he was driving he was
causing chaos though in the streets of London actually yeah
I was gonna say maybe that's why I know it I feel like it's
quite a typical thing for like UK children to read when
they're a kid i feel like yeah oh vicky your voice don't
worry it's it's okay does it hurt no it actually doesn't i
think it's because i'm taking all the bacon oh all right
here we go all right hell is over there how do we get there
um we're gonna jump jump in the water i made it get in the
water oh i is okay i'm gonna eat more wheat yeah i eat you
eat your wheat it's so funny watching you eat it swim and
eat multitasking yeah does satan show up satan it looks like
the um he looks like the judge
oh the judge is satan can we get up there i wonder There's
something...
Oh, I think that's a horse.
The hell doesn't look so bad, to be honest.
Yeah!
That's not that bad.
Yeah.
Anything below us?
Make some obsidian out of that lava, and then make another
port.
Sometimes there's whales in the water.
Yeah, we go to...
Are they friendly whales?
Yeah, they are.
Yeah, you could go to hell in Minecraft.
Oh, wow.
Oh, that is...
skeleton horse yeah the skelly horse they're safe they're
safe pretty oh can i tell you that was the question you
should be able to ride it these things hurt you um you won't
let me ride him but you used to be able to i guess they
patched it out no no don't want to ride him whoa look at
that house um also nothing here is friendly um you see a cow
it's not friendly including that cow yeah that is not
friendly oh oh he's a cute i know he's a zombie cow oh i see
oh my god me apparently i am the i am the oh good thing
there's no pvp zombie cow take him down i think we would
have died a lot more times is that his brain like on the
outside of his head i think so it's kind of freaky this guy
i thought it was a little hat what is this guy this guy
looks bad news there thank you magic user oh he's a race oh
my god oh it's cool whoa good job guys nice what did he drop
what did he um i think i might have took it by accident he
dropped essence of fire you guys want some essence of fire
sounds delicious i have no idea what it is but let's give
you some essence of fire oh that's my sword oh that uh i
think you need that thank you drop this essence of fire you
go essence of fire for everybody yeah take it take it will
my will my will my mace break if I is it breaking soon it is
you can have mine it's not as broken oh thank you yeah is it
a little bit better than yours it is a little bit okay nice
I like the music yeah It's very atmospheric.
Do you hear this music, Phoebe?
Yeah, it's just soft, I think.
Oh, this place isn't that big, though.
Oh, cute.
Oh.
What?
That's what this sounds like.
Like, oh.
Uh-oh.
Some opera or something going on there.
Can we do, like, one at a time?
Yeah, yeah.
They're aggroed on me, so just get them.
They're aggroed on me.
I'll just bring them.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, so Mitch confirmed.
Yeah.
Get him.
Yeah!
Let's go.
Yeah, baby.
Yeah, it does sound very, it does sound very dark souls.
Fine.
It's this BGM.
How do we get up?
Let's see.
Oh, I have some.
Whoa, I've never been in one of these places before.
I'm excited.
Is it evil?
We can do it, baby.
We can do this.
They have houses.
Wait, they have beds.
Use this.
Oh, you got it?
Oh, we got it.
You got it?
Okay, good, good.
I think I put down one block too many.
No, it's okay.
Your little house.
Oh, cute.
Oh, we could set up camp in hell.
In hell.
They have a whole little village.
Oh, take that.
Take that.
Oh, some salt.
Yeah.
What else is in here?
Oh, they got, like, a castle up there and stuff?
What's going on?
All right, little guys.
We're all set up here.
Are you putting down, like, a furnace and stuff?
There's more beds and stuff.
There's more beds here already.
Cool.
More beds?
Yeah, hell bed.
Wow, this place is so cute.
What a nice place.
Yeah.
where do you guys find the bed this could be our vacation
home in the building yeah the heck is down there i don't
want to know oh oh this is some good stuff well it's like a
little little merchant tables up here oh raw beef maybe they
have a farmer's market sometimes oh i see inside oh guys a
little table and chairs that's lovely to nowhere.
The door to nowhere?
Oh, wow.
Wait, they have another Oshikod statue we can take.
Heck, yeah.
Yeah, this door right here.
So we're new.
There you are.
This is such a cute little village.
I guess...
Oh, it's nice.
It's ours now.
Yeah, we live here now.
Oh, there is a furnace, wow.
I wonder who lived here right whoever did they're definitely
not living here now so it's like pretty oh there's so many
spider webs what's up here oh no not not my heck am i where
are you i have no idea oh i see you oh there you are hi oh
more crates oh nice nice assistant Wait, where'd you guys
find the beds?
Did you rest in them?
I rested in one, yeah.
Where were they?
We should probably all do the same respawn point.
Um, mine was, I think, right in here.
I grabbed one.
And then there was one down here in the first building.
Oh, yes, yes.
Yeah, there's one in here.
Nice.
I'll go get the one down here.
No!
She loves pressing G.
It was over here?
I think.
Yes.
You got it?
Got it.
Okay.
I wonder if we dig here.
What did you name your beds?
Huh?
Oh, this is my hell bed.
Hell bed.
If we dug here, I wonder if we'll get the dinosaurs.
Is that how you think?
find them apparently they're under let's do it shall we dig
yes we dig to dino right you guys um okay i wonder if we can
get there just came out oh i can see i can see minto and
through the window how do i get there oh oh like that all
right for when i need to make some kill okay
Dig to Dino, everybody.
Dig to Dino.
All right.
My digging thing is broken.
Is that okay?
I will do my best.
Yeah, I'm gathering supplies so I can make some new ones
too.
Oh, can I take this one?
Which one?
Oh, that's a hole.
It's not a...
Oh, no, no.
Yeah.
Crude pickaxe.
That should be there.
Yeah.
Crude pickaxe.
That's what I...
That's what we're all using.
Dig to Dino!
Take the dinos!
Yeah!
So which dinosaurs you're hoping to find down here, Minto?
Um...
I don't even know what to expect.
Something like...
What's your fab one again?
What's... What's he called?
Well, it's a pterosaur which is the Ketzalcoat Atlas.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Oh.
He's cool.
I like the ones with the really hard head.
Yeah!
Oh.
How are you guys so low already?
Okay, I'll come in.
You can just...
You can honestly be my little passenger princess if you want
to just...
Stay down.
I'll dig and you can just...
Watch, baby.
Yippee!
Oh.
Yeah, the Pachycephalosaurus.
Yeah.
I
always thought to get stuck down here.
It would.
Wait.
Actually, wait, what am I doing?
I'm digging like a Minecraft.
I need to be digging like a hightail.
Boy.
I've lost you guys.
You just dig down enough to where you can jump.
You don't have to, because like, in Minecraft, you kind of
have to build, like, stairs.
Because there's no climbing.
But in this game, there's climbing.
Well, I'm doing something that's dumb in both Minecraft and
hightail.
I'm just digging directly down.
Oh, you're digging directly down?
Okay.
Let's go!
I'm digging directly down.
Yeah, let's go!
I'll go faster this way!
I have no idea what I'm doing.
I'll hit something eventually, surely, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly!
Oh wait, what's that?
Oh.
Yeah.
Dig straight down, dig straight down, dig straight down.
Oh my god.
Mito, are you okay?
Dig straight down, yeah!
Okay.
Okay, I'm in a different kind of rock now.
Me too, me too!
Yeah!
I have absolutely no idea where I am.
I might fall into the lava.
You'll hit something, alright, says my chat.
Oh.
I don't know.
Oh, the music changed.
Wait.
Whoa, what is that?
Where's that orb of light, you guys?
Wait, where are you, Phoebe?
I don't know.
There's like an orb of light that I'm seeing every time I go
down a block.
Oh, wait.
Oh!
Oh, hi.
Okay, I found you.
Hello.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, wow!
I think that's a dinosaur!
Or something!
You have not one!
Baby!
Baby, you found one!
It's a bird of some sort.
A bird!
Actually, I don't sound dinosaurs, a bird, but birds and
dinosaurs are related to it.
Wait, but there shouldn't be a bird in the...
You found?
Wait, how far down are you?
That's a good question.
I'm going to try to not die when I drop down.
Let's see.
Words are dinosaurs.
Oh, hi.
Oh, oh.
Hi.
Oh, my God.
Where are you?
What is...
Whoa!
Dinosaurs are real!
We need to find you.
Where are you?
Um...
It looks like I'm not too far.
Wait.
You guys are digging in a completely different...
I just dug down.
Oh, yeah.
I'm somewhere completely different.
No!
I wish you were here.
I want to see the dinosaur!
Yeah!
I just...
Is it cool?
Is it a cool area?
Yeah, well, I mean, it's not that cool.
It's not that cool.
Is that your dead body?
Vicky?
Oh.
Oh, it was too far down.
It was too far down.
Oh.
I mean, on the plus side, I can go find Phoebe now.
Where's the dinosaur?
Maintel, I will follow you to my death.
I might die too.
I might hit...
Through the hole of Pytale.
What is this?
Oh, this is...
Did you get to the really dark rock that's like really hard
to dig through?
No, I did not actually.
I'm going to go find that.
I'm going to go find the hole that I...
That I...
Oh.
Okay, I'm going to...
But if I fell directly down into it.
Oh, it's magma rock.
Is that a good thing?
Oh, Vicky, hi.
Hi, I'm...
Oh.
Okay, so if I dig down...
Oh, hello.
Oh, you're here.
Okay, where did you dig from?
Yes.
Okay, maybe...
This is probably my hole.
This is my hole.
It was made for me.
Okay, I'm digging towards where are you?
Let's maybe not dig directly, directly down.
I will follow...
Watch out.
I feel like...
Okay.
Wait, should I die so I can follow you guys?
Oh, wait.
Yeah, maybe.
But how...
Wait, okay, Vicky, you come back up here.
Where'd you go?
Let's go get some...
Let's go get some quick axes first.
Okay.
But how will you go down your hole, Phoebe?
You went really far, no?
I did, but I feel like if I fall down the hole, I'm just
going to fall directly to my desk.
Yeah, thank you.
I'm going to get some rubble.
Now, I might be able.
I think I just...
Okay, I think I just fell further.
I'm just going to wait in the hole.
Okay.
I don't know what's happening.
Let's make the hole a little bit wider.
I'm almost to you guys.
Maybe I'll find your hole.
Oh my gosh.
We will see you soon, Minto.
Yes.
Maybe.
Maybe if I get closer, then when I dig down, I'll hit the
dinosaurs.
Maybe.
We will find them.
We will.
okay it's gonna be like our very own jungalia i'm like right
next to you guys yeah it is gonna be our own jungalia okay
i'm going down now i'm digging down okay i'm trying to be i
don't know the digging strats i'm just i'm just passenger
princessing i'm sorry no it's okay thank you for letting me
pass i'm making stairs no no you seem you seem You have to
definitely know what you're doing, Quartz Titan.
This music sounds wild.
Just make sure you don't fall directly down into the hole,
okay, Vicky?
I'll try.
It's a very, very long way down.
I don't see their name tag.
I don't think you can see name tags in this game.
Wait, did I dig too deep?
Unfortunately, I don't think so.
Some people are saying I dug too deep.
That's a thing?
I'm too low?
You can dig too deep?
What?
Is it like a very specific area where the dinosaurs reside?
I guess so?
Bless you.
Thank you.
Okay, I need to craft another pickaxe.
They are not a difficult rock.
Thank you.
Maybe if I just keep digging around, I'll reach it.
Why?
They elude me ever so.
No, Minto, we will find them.
If you come over, if you start digging towards where we are,
maybe...
I'm right at you.
You're right at me.
Yeah.
Then you should be able to...
Maybe if I go up.
And the dinosaurs hate me.
Minto, you will find them.
Whoa.
If you find us, Phoebe's been doing a very, like, a very
good steps down the hole.
pretty safe.
I might have to die.
I don't know how to see coordinates in this game, guys.
Oh,
shoot!
Shoot!
Oh, no!
Do you die?
Oh!
Uh-oh.
No!
Quartz Titan!
Don't do what I did.
Do not do what I did.
What are you doing?
I'm sorry.
My back is like... Or anybody.
I've been sitting all day.
Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no.
Oh no.
Are you falling?
No.
How do you, how do you hold a torch at the same time, she
said?
There was not time to find out.
I watched you fall.
Did you see me?
Wait.
Wait, you were there, Mento?
You were there?
Mento!
I was all I was trying to do all I was trying to do was hold
the torch at the same time because it was so dark I can see
what I was doing
Okay, I'm coming back.
I'm coming back.
I got okay.
Where are you?
Okay.
Oh, right.
Is that a dinosaur?
Where is the hole?
Did you see it?
Did you find it?
I see some guys around right yeah yeah wait no no please let
me see oh my god he's so cute you got to see it he farted oh
evil guy oh i see i'm flying um barrett oh my god we made it
to the dino who's okay what the heck have i got myself into
he's just looking at me you okay i think he's friend i think
these guys are friend they're friend oh my god oh shoot oh
oh my god oh he's so cute oh he's so cute they're like all
glowy wow oh not the burnt skeleton oh no wait are they back
at our base or how do i how do i get to you should we should
we sleep one so I can, like, see where you guys are.
I don't know how to get to you guys.
I'm back in that hole again.
I can't sleep.
Back in the hole.
Wait, there might be...
There's a tree house here.
Oh.
I might be able to get a bed so I could sleep.
Is anyone...
Is anyone, like, near enough to the hole that they can show
me where it is?
Unfortunately, I'm in the hole.
No problem.
Okay.
Oh, but if you go, like, past the...
Oh.
Um...
I mean, you could see me on the map, right?
yes um quartz titan okay so i'm going a little bit the other
way okay if i go this way i can't show you mine either
because i like had to go up from my hole so don't follow
mine okay i see mint i see i think i'm like right on top of
quartz titan okay all right so it must be somewhere here
there should be a hole okay yes i see the hole you might
have to fall a little bit in order to get to where I'm at.
Wow!
Oh my god!
I'm so happy for you.
Oh, this is so... I'm sorry.
Okay.
They're real.
The dinosaurs are real.
Oh!
Oh, what just happened?
Oh.
Bamboo look.
The music's kind of epic here.
Okay.
I'm nearly there.
Chili.
Yes, I'll eat this chili.
He's walking on air.
what else have i got to eat oh tree sap can i eat tree sap
essence of life essence of life i'm like i'm just trying to
eat something can i eat seeds can i eat a pine cone okay all
right all right i'm just gonna be very careful i'm gonna
live here oh are you okay what was that Goodbye, world.
No, me, don't.
Did you say you're spawned down there?
No, there is no bed.
It's okay.
Oh.
Slowly but surely, I am creating...
You do?
Yes.
I'm here.
Oh, hi.
Oh, I'm so happy to see.
I'm so happy.
If you want to join us in mining down...
Yeah, of course.
Oh, gosh, where?
Oh, geez.
so dark.
We're finally...
We can finally be together again.
Yeah!
Where are you guys?
Are you guys by where we started digging?
We're in a hole somewhere.
Okay, I'll find you.
Yes.
Is that me?
Uh, you see us on the map?
Yeah, yeah, I'll find you.
Don't worry, I'll find you.
Okay.
We are slowly but surely.
Nope.
Fibi's making a very nice very nice...
Very nice path down.
Is this the correct way?
Let me double...
Wait, I see you guys!
I see you guys!
I'm right above you!
Yes!
Woohoo!
Oh, yeah?
Yeah.
Okay.
No, Phoebe is like an expert at crafting these safe...
Safe holes.
Honestly.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, this is good.
I'm a safety expert.
Ahiri has hired me to create safe holes.
The trap.
Oh, hello!
Mendo, we're together!
We're together now!
Dinosaurs together!
I can see my items!
Oh, I can see my items!
Oh, yeah!
We're so close!
Oh, Shaka.
The problem is, from there, I'm not sure what to do.
Like, from there.
Oh, is it too high up?
It's pretty high up.
Okay.
So we might just have to, like, find other places to dig.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me know when he gets tired.
dig some thank you thank you guys i don't understand the
digging ways i'm in awe okay it's okay i'm also not sure i'm
being the most efficient right now oh sorry we're in the way
there he is it's okay sorry we're all like stacked on top of
each other standing on top of each other yeah okay actually
if you could take over for a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
I will also take a few bites of my bread.
I can't see.
You get some of that wheat.
Says the wheat titan.
Yes.
Processed wheat.
Oh, yeah.
Is it that high?
So I thought...
I don't know.
Okay, maybe...
Oh, I see my drop down.
Oh, okay.
Uh, we can build up...
We can build a staircase, maybe.
Let
me do this.
Something exciting.
Yeah, exciting.
It's all so exciting.
I'm so excited to see the dinosaurs!
Do you see the dinosaurs again, Vicky?
No, this will be my first time.
You might be able to see some from here, actually.
Oh, I see you guys flying.
Yeah, this guy looks pretty evil, though.
So be careful.
Oh, okay.
Dead Setsu no hole.
Oh,
no.
You guys are doing great.
Yeah, it's a little bit to the left, a little bit to the
right.
Yeah, lovely.
Yeah, doing great, guys.
My pickaxe is a bit oversea.
Oh, I can make another one.
Good.
I'm not sure that I'll be able to.
Unless you guys have some extra rubble.
I do have some rubble.
Rubble.
Oh my god, it's so far.
So close and yet.
Does cobble count?
Is that useful?
Oh, you do get rubble from cobble, actually.
So if you break the cobble, like this stuff, this kind of...
This stuff right here around us, it'll give you more rubble.
I have a ton of cobbles, so I can give it to you guys
anytime.
Thank you.
Oh, how close are you?
We're so close.
We're close, actually.
We're close.
We could probably drop from here.
Yeah, we could drop from here.
You think so?
Yep.
It was safe?
You can do it, Vicky, I believe.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yay!
Oh, my gosh.
So exciting.
I thought these guys were nice, but the Raptors are not very
nice.
Oh, they're not.
Where are the Raptors?
Is that how you die?
Yeah, I died to a party of Raptors.
There was a whole flock of them.
Do you like this guy?
He looks kind right now, but he's actually not kind.
Dinosaur!
He's so cute!
Exciting.
Oh, look at this glow-in-the-dark guy.
Yeah, the glow-the-dark guy's cool.
I like you!
Oh, I think these ones hurt you.
I punch him.
Wow, dinosaur is real!
Whoa, look at this guy.
Yeah.
Whoa, this is the coolest place we've been so far.
Yeah, I agree.
So are you not chill, dude?
Are you chill?
He's chill, but I think he's just bugged out.
His friends, though, are not very chill.
I see.
Specifically, that guy is chill.
Yeah, just this guy is chill.
The music is so cool.
I love it.
Oh, I think these blocks.
Yeah, over here is the treehouse.
Treehouse.
Oh, wait.
Oh, close.
This is close to where I died.
Oh, it's bamboo.
Are you punching the block?
Here.
Wait, where?
You want these red blocks.
Here, here, here.
They look like mushroom.
Red mushroom block.
Yeah, cute.
What's that?
Do-do-do-do.
I like the music.
Yeah, it's good.
Oh, it's just a common flower.
Oh, my stuff!
Uh-uh.
Oh, shit.
Oh, what happened?
Hold up.
I got you.
Ouch.
This is why it's a tree house.
Hold on.
Where did he go?
Yeah, there's some stuff here.
Is that one of you guys?
Oh, that's mine, yeah.
Wait, don't run.
Don't run.
I got him.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah, arrows.
Oh, oh, Vicky.
Oh, no.
It's okay, because I got to see the dinosaurs.
I got to see them.
I'm so sorry.
I thought I had my ball equipped.
Come back.
Where did he go?
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Ah!
You got him, I believe.
I don't know you can do it guys I died
oh go on Phoebe go on take him down I'm I'm satisfied I got
to see I got to see them yeah honestly I'm feeling pretty
good to see them we all got to see the dinosaurs I'm gonna
try to avenge you no no where did he go where did he go such
a chaotic staircase Oh!
So dark.
Okay, he's gone.
He's like gone.
He's gone?
Did he run off?
A little coward.
He said there's no...
There's no...
There's no beds up here?
Nah, I couldn't see any.
There are like bird creatures in the tree.
Cute.
This place is awesome.
Oh my gosh.
finally got to see the dinosaurs.
Yeah, I'm so glad we can see them.
Oh, wait, how'd you die?
What happened?
How'd you die?
Okay, I just want to join you guys.
Oh, we are.
Oh, I see how you died.
I see how you died.
Oh, my God.
Yeah!
That was lava.
Woo!
Let's go!
Lava?
Where are you guys?
Should we meet up for a final...
We can meet.
Do you think you could get back down here or no?
Okay, Phoebe, let's die.
Let's die, Phoebe.
Let's die, okay.
Let's jump from a high place.
No, wait.
That wasn't high enough?
Oh, okay.
One more time.
Oh, thanks, guys.
Yeah, I can't see a blooming thing, I'll be honest.
Oh, wait, that wasn't high enough.
That wasn't high enough.
I want one of the flying guys to kill me.
Oh, here!
I heard something scary.
Yeah, kill me!
Kill me!
Is he a chill guy?
Oh, no, he's not a chill guy.
He was kind of glitched out, but I put myself in front of
him and he killed me.
Kill me!
Wait, actually, what if I go up for this guy?
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, I can see you guys.
Oh, I can see Phoebe.
I'm right behind you too.
Hi.
We can't watch the sunrise here.
Yeah.
It's so pretty from here.
Look at the shadows of the trees and the beautiful vast sky.
Oh.
What an adventure, eh, guys.
Yeah, what an adventure.
What an adventure.
We found dinosaurs.
Oh, I didn't think we would.
Thank you, guys.
No, I'm so happy.
We were not going to give up till we found your dinosaurs.
Wow.
So awesome.
And next time we'll be fine, we'll go find them in real life
at Jungalia.
Yeah.
Yes.
I'd love to.
Woo!
Rest up, Vicky.
Let's go.
Rest, rest, rest.
Yes.
Oh, thank you.
Um, we, we have an idle meeting, but yes.
Well, we have a meeting, but...
Well, after that, you need to rest, rest, rest.
After that, hi.
What's up you, my star?
Hi.
Yeah.
That was so fun.
Thank you, Minto, High Tail, Senpai, and Phoebe Minecraft,
Senpai, for showing me the ways.
It was so much fun.
What an adventure.
Thank you, thank you, Wheat, Senpai, for showing me the
ways.
way of organic organic uh oh to me i didn't know you could
eat the weeds i've learned no no i might i might try to i
don't need yeah actual guys we're not just all going for
that i mean at the same time okay actual meeting that's why
we gotta go what's the either way we probably would have
gone what's a different item meeting go in the bathroom oh
no it's a real meeting we do work Yeah, guys, guys, what do
you think we're doing?
Isn't it like a thing, though?
Girls go to the bathroom and together?
The girls that bathe in together stay together.
Team Den said to forever.
We'll let you guys interpret what that means.
We are scheduled weekly bathroom trip.
Actually, you know how there's like the three hearts and our
colors all together like that?
That's actually what our toilet looks like.
so anyways on to the real or fake idol meeting you guys
decide we'll let you guys picture that you decide um this is
fine thank you guys it was so much fun thank you thank you i
want to play more with you yeah one more next adventure we
went to so many places though we did yeah the deaths so
funny oh my god so much oh my gosh so much fun yeah well
i'll see you guys you know at the idol meeting at the idol
meeting yes yes thank you den she for watching thank you den
she Vicky, you better not talk in the meeting.
But I love yapping.
We know.
You can yapping the text chat.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right, everybody.
Thank you, everybody.
We love you.
Thank you, Denchi.
Yeah, thank you, Denchi.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
A happy day.
Bye-bye.